ready to go chair i'm sending you live
now lovely stuff thank you very much
okay good evening everybody and welcome
to this evening's virtual meeting of
uh the planning committee for stratford
uh district council my name is
councillor peter richards and i will be
chairing
the meeting tonight um we do have a
packed agenda so we will try and move
things
through things as quickly as we can
whilst maintaining a full
um debate and uh open and transparent
debate and just remind members that we
um we approved a change to our
constitution uh
last month um that requires a limit of
three hours to
our meeting um if we are
uh listening to an item as we're
approaching
that three hours and unlikely to finish
before that we will continue until it's
done
anything that doesn't get heard within
that time limit or prior to that three
hour limit being reached
uh will and i'm afraid be deferred until
a future meeting i just wanted to make
both members aware of that but also
remember the public that may be watching
a little bit of uh housekeeping uh if i
may um you would have all been provided
with the council's etiquette for virtual
meetings in advance of tonight but to
reiterate a few of these saving
points please make sure your device is
fully charged or is
charging remember to mute your
microphones when you're not speaking and
keep them muted unless you are invited
to speak
um if you are wishing to speak please
indicate so in the chat i have it open
and i will call you in at an appropriate
time
again remember to unmute yourself in
order to speak and then meet yourself
again
um when you have done
if for any reason you encounter any it
issues um them
causing you to drop out of the virtual
meeting then please make every effort to
get back in as soon as you can
if you are unable to for whatever reason
you will have been deemed to have left
the meeting at that stage
and we will continue with the agenda
provided we remain
corrupt there are two numbers that have
been placed into
the chat so again if you have any issues
getting back in again please do call
that
and we will get you back in as soon as
we can
um i can also confirm that just before
we went live
um in the presence of our officers and
our particularly our legal officer
that we have made checks to ensure that
all members of the committee
are in attendance and they have
confirmed in the presence of the legal
officer that they can
see and hear the proceedings and that
they have read their reports
including the update sheet
we have a number of offices with us
tonight as well as as we usually would
um
uh they come from uh democratic services
legal and planning so our democratic
services officer for the evening is
olivia quinn
our legal officer is ross chambers
we also have our planners uh alison
willis paul thompson
charlotte dix and izzy howell and we
have we have graced with two planning
managers this evening
um primarily we have tracy humphries who
will be the lead planning manager
tracy has indicated a um a disclosure
for the first item in that she lives in
henley so we have dale barker joining us
and he will be the planning manager for
the first item tracy i believe you have
a
statement you very quickly want to make
for us
you are currently muted tracy i'm afraid
so if you would kindly unmute
thank you chairman yes uh just to advise
members that the committee manager's
function
is to provide impartial advice and to
assist members
in their decision taking fabulous thank
you very much
indeed okay uh let's go straight into
our agenda for the night then so
first of all we have apologies for
absence olivia would you mind please
giving us the apologies chair we've got
apologies from councillors curtis
eden and paris and councillor jennings
who's also given his apologies but he'll
be speaking as ward member on the first
item
lovely stuff thank you very much um and
next item is our disclosures of interest
members if you could please indicate
in the chat if you have any disclosures
while you're doing that
i will make a few um to start us off on
first item which is application 2006
ful that's henry and lardon sports club
um i have
uh received a number of uh
correspondence both by phone
and email on that item um
i am very much here with an open mind
and will continue to be part of the
discussion of the debate
i know our other members have received
similar emails
and potentially phone calls as well
certainly a wealth of correspondence on
that item
so we'll take it as read that everyone
is making the same
disclosure i have also received
correspondence
and i believe again to all members so
we'll take it as read that everyone has
received this
uh for application 1903 574
ful which is lunan's farm um
and finally we conducted a site visit
yesterday
to the second application we're hearing
which is nineteen zero three
one one three ful that's kelsteen
uh in welfare on aven those in
attendance were myself
councillor fleming councillor mills and
councillor henshaw seraphin and that was
uh alongside uh uh playing officer
allison
willis uh and also the ward member
councillor pertiguella
we also have councillor adam wishing to
make a disclosure counselor adam thank
you chairman
um they just relate to the ones that
you've um
already mentioned lovely stuff
okay and councillor fleming as well
please
thank you chairman um i'm not really
sure this is relevant but in in view of
sort of openness and
transparency um i do know
khao stein in welford we haven't
communicated for probably
quite a few years now but i just thought
it was relevant that i declare the fact
that i didn't know the family
okay lovely thank you very much um and
counselor henshaw
sarafin um has said on item four he's
received emails uh
but he's here with an open mind
counseling stefan do you want to uh say
that verbally for the
for the benefit of everyone watching
please yes i have received emails
and uh i do come to this uh committee
with an open mind
thank you lovely stuff thank you very
much
um unless there are any other
disclosures i'm not seeing any in the
chat
some shaking heads okay lovely in that
case um we will move to our next item
which is the minutes
members could i please have a thumbs up
a nod
a wave something to indicate from each
of you that you're willing the
to confirm uh the minutes of meeting
hell on 23rd of september and 7th of
october this year
and then i can sign them that is a
thumbs up all round
marvelous there we go fabulous i will do
that when we are next in the office
um okay let's get straight to our first
application
which is application 2006 ful
as henley and arden sports club our
presenting officer is
alison willis alison it's over to you
thanks mr chairman uh i'm just gonna
re-share my screen so it doesn't seem to
be moving
okay
okay i can see your screen now at the
moment we have
a list of the planning applications for
this evening
can you can you see that that's changed
uh all i can see at the moment is the
order of planning applications
uh list i can see nothing else
okay let me try to share that again no
problem at all
jewels of rural broadband
um
can can you see that now
all right there we go we've got a map on
screen yes we're good
mr chairman so
um this is an application for the change
of use and modifications to warwickshire
college sports centre
to create a new training base together
with car parking
pitch works landscaping and associated
development
on a site to the south of henley and
arden
location is shown by the black dot
the site is outside the conservation
area but is in the green belt
and the special landscape area the
nearest listed buildings to the north
are ardenhurst preparatory school and
ardenhurst
school memorial
here is a recent aerial view of the site
showing the application site outlined in
red
the college building here and hall
with existing access here and car
parking
the building closed at the end of
december in 2019
and the community uses ceased at that
point
the existing floodlit pitch the
artificial grass pitch
and grass pitch to the south
and there's a grass training area to the
north here
sorry to cut across you allison i do
apologize at the
moment um i'm only seeing a um a google
map image i'm not sure if that's the
same for all members or if that's what's
going out live
um i can see your mouse wiggling yeah
that
that's the slide ah perfect thank you
that's what it's supposed to be at this
point
um so there are two pitches outside the
application
site here and here which belong to this
building
which used to be part of warwickshire
college but now has permission
for a care home
[Music]
this slide shows a view of the existing
access
the site is quite private with a dense
hedgerow and
mature trees along the road
this slide shows the existing college
building which closed at the end of
december 2019
the 2007 permission has a community use
agreement for
internal facilities including the sports
hall in the gym
the community use agreement does not
include the use of the outside pictures
this is the sports hall
this is a photo montage of the site
taken from the west
standing on the grass pitch left to
right you can see the artificial grass
pitch with floodlights
the college building and the sports hall
behind the trees
the existing car park with 89 spaces
the majority of the works of the
building are internal
including the introduction of the first
floor in the sports hall to give
additional accommodation
there are very little changes to the
outside of the building
additional windows here
on the front elevation overlooking the
car park
a new door in the rear and a new path
at the rear of the building
the artificial grass pitch is to be
upgraded
from a 2g to a 3g pitch suitable for a
different range of sports
including rugby football but not hockey
the existing grass pitch here is to be
upgraded
electric vehicle charging points are to
be installed in the car park
the community use of the artificial
pitch would be secured with a community
use agreement as detailed in the report
and the applicant has also offered to
contribute 50 000 pounds for henley and
arden community sports project
to be agreed with the parish council to
help mitigate for the loss of the 2g
pitch and sports hall
that's the end of the presentation mr
chairman
mr chairman there are five updates as
per the
update sheet and the recommendation
mr chairman is that the application be
granted
subject to conditions and notes and
subject to the completion of a section
106
legal agreement as outlined in the
report for the reasons delegate
detailed in the report the wording and
numbering of which is delegated to
offices
thank you marvelous allison thank you
very much for that we will now bring in
our first
speaker who uh is from the uh henley in
arden and beaudesert
parish council councilor mariana
bainbridge
counselor are you there you will need to
press start and six to unmute yourself
star in six to unmute
i'm not sure if you've been able to hear
us or can hear us
cancel that star six to unmute your
yourself
i'm not sure if our parish counselor is
able to hear me or not
uh indeed i can't see that they have
unmuted just to reiterate this is star
and six to unmute yourself
what we may do is uh i will ask our
democratic services if you could kindly
see if you can get hold of um our
speaker from the parish council
uh and we will come back to them shortly
um and move
to our second speaker on the list um
which is uh roger cooper
mr cooper if you are there if you press
start and sixth one mute yourself
can you hear me i can indeed
you've got three minutes um we will give
you a 30 second warning and if you can
stay on
uh once you're done there may be some
questions from our
members um otherwise whenever you're
ready please do begin
okay good evening the image on the
screen
says it all it's all about people
these are everyday people stratford
district residents
looking after their own health and
well-being they are your
constituents 1 500 people per week
enjoyed the henley sports centre young
and old
fit and not so fit gym users
some sent there by henry doctors for
obesity heart disease and other health
reasons
and then there are those playing sports
netball
crickets and gymnastics a crowd of
children and parents waiting for a
football game
and a very full car park more
importantly you'll see
two groups of children all of which have
soluble palsy
in wheelchairs the older ones playing
basketball and the younger ones dancing
to music
the highlight of their week 500 visitors
per week
this sports centre was only granted
permission on condition that the
community use order was in place
to keep these facilities open to local
people
all day seven days a week it's operated
like that for over 10 years
and became henley's best kept secret the
planning condition is still in place
under wasps application more than 97
of this use will cease to be available
the gym will be closed
the sports hall closed the fitness
studio closed
and the 3g pitch really only suitable
for rugby
as the markings will only be full update
and there'll be no football goal posts
and again only available at wasps
discretion
this closure is totally contrary to
national guidelines
sdc core strategy and sdc active
community strategy
sport england have a holding objection
in place
so if you support this application you
are voting against
sdc's own policies i'm told wcg could
not make
it work financially not surprising as
they failed to ask people to actually
pay
they had no experience of running a
standalone sports facility
wasps do not represent the only solution
to the closure
of this site the hsca have a business
plan
and are ready to purchase the site and
run this as a community interest company
the funding is in place with the grenley
trust and the second charity
we've kept in touch with the users and
we know most have not
found suitable alternative venues and
want to come back
without the head office costs of a large
organization
we know we can make this viable even
with covered restrictions
to provide a real service to the
community without public funding
i've sent more details to each of you
please vote to reject this application
and show your concern for the health and
well-being of the community
and all the policies and strategies that
you've signed up for
i'm happy to take your questions
mr cooper thank you very much that was
well within your time
um members do we have any questions for
mr cooper
please indicate in a chat if you do
i'm not seeing anything come through
just yet um i'll ask you a question if i
may mr cooper i note um
on page 18 of our report that the
property was actively marketed
well sorry wcg say it was actively
marketed
and we met with wcg and
when we asked to see a copy of that they
could not produce anything other than
the supposed wording of an email that
they say the land agent
sent out to um to a number of addresses
there is no evidence that actually
actual marketing took place
and i honestly think sbc need to see
that
uh very thoroughly
okay thank you my my question was going
to be was did you express an interest
then
i'm gathering from that that you you you
didn't see the
the marketing so um
nobody in henley seemed to know it was
for sale including the jcc
who had it in the national in their
local development
neighborhood development plan and said
we we would want to keep alert to it
and they did not know which does sound
very strange
okay that answers my question thank you
mr cooper councillor mills you have a
question
yes thank you very much good evening
it's just very very simple
um was there any consultation with the
with the parish council
well after the event after we were aware
we have met with the jpc
they've given us support they were
unanimous in
in rejecting it and in fact the lady
that you should have just heard from
will tell you the results of the local
ballot that's been held recently
i see no other members registering that
they wish to ask you a question so mr
cooper
thank you very much um i would suggest
it's probably best if you
if you hang up your phone now and then
continue to observe uh
on our online portal
thank you for giving me the chance to
speak pleasure thank you
very much okay we're going to try again
now to see if we can get our parish
councillor
uh in council mariana brainbridge are
you there counsellor
we've got the applicant in chairs
bear with me i believe the um the
parachute counselor may be watching
online because i can hear a delay of my
own voice oh
i am but i'm can you hear me
we can cancel castle mariana could you
could you do me a favor could you please
either mute or turn off the live
feed hello
hello hello ah
could you please do me a favor and turn
off or mute your live feed it's
interfering
with both with with the procedure of the
the meeting but also i think it's it's
conflicting with
your your phone and ability to hear us
i think that's got it can you hear us
still counsellor
cancer brain bridge i can i can still
still see you being
part of the meeting but i'm i haven't
heard you speak for a moment or two
councilman bainbridge if you're there if
you could indicate that you are still
there that would be very helpful
we may need to adjourn in order to get
you in so that we can hear you speak
prior to bringing the applicants in
members i'm just going to give it
another couple of seconds so that we can
see if we can get
here hello hello counselor bainbridge
yes i can i can hear you fabulous we can
hear you now
oh good good stuff so
um you have three minutes uh we'll give
you a 30 second warning
if you could stay on once you finish
speaking uh counsellors may have
questions for you
otherwise whenever you're ready to go
please do start
you finish speaking uh counselors may
have questions for you
otherwise whenever you're ready to go
please do start right
uh but in henley in arden joint parish
council
object to this
joint parish council object to this
planning application
not to the proposed physical alterations
but to the principle of the loss of this
important community facility
i would like to quote from to
counselor bainbridge i'm just going to
stop you there for just a second
i can hear the live feed in the
background it is delayed because it is
being recorded and then
sent out to the internet please could
you turn off
the live recording in the background and
use your handset of your phone
to listen to the meeting and contribute
to it right
recording in the background and use your
handset of your
phone to listen to the meeting and
contribute to it
can you hear me now we can hear you
we'll restart our time
that would be great sorry right but
desert and henley and arden joint parish
council object to this planning
application
not to the proposed physical alterations
but to the principle of the loss of this
important community facility i would
like to quote from two documents
which we feel are relevant to this
application
the national planning policy framework
the nppf
and the strategic council
call strategies that would be great
right are we starting again
no sorry please please do carry on um
another speaker had unmuted themselves
and we were getting feedback from sorry
as well
right the national worker the national
planning policy framework
and the stratfor naval district council
core strategy
the nppf paragraph 91
says planning policy and decisions
should aim to achieve
healthy inclusive and safe places which
enable
and support healthy lifestyles
especially where this would address
identified local health and wellbeing
needs
paragraph 92 plan positively for the
provision
and use of community facilities such as
sports venues to enhance the sustainable
sustainability of those communities
see guard against the unnecessary loss
of valued facilities and services
particularly where this would reduce the
community's ability to meet its
day-to-day needs
paragraph 97 existing open space
sports and recreational buildings and
land including playing fields
should not be lost to the community
unless
an assessment has been undertaken which
is clearly shows
the open space buildings and land
to be surplus to requirements or the
loss resulting from the proposed
would be replaced by equivalent or
better provision
in terms of quality and quantity in a
suitable location
from the stratford-on-avon district
council core strategy healthy
communities policy cs25
the provision of new and enhanced
community cultural sport
and leisure facilities will be
encouraged as a way of promoting healthy
inclusive communities provide
more opportunities and facilities for
children and young people
encourage more residents to get involved
in sport leisure
and recreation activities
the provision at the site catered for a
wide range of sports and recreations
in line with the nppf and the core
strategy
the proposal is for a training center
for a professional rugby team which will
almost totally exclude the local
community
the suggested alternative provision at
moreton morrill
some 15 miles away would be difficult if
not impossible
to reach by public transport transport
by
private car is not in accordance with
the principles of stain
sustainability set out in the core
strategy
i could go on but you are all very aware
of these documents
we would ask you to consider this
application with relevance to these
policies
laid down in the mppf and the course
strategy
when making your decision thank you very
much
thank you very much for that um i
apologize for the technical difficulties
we were having there
members do you have any questions for
the counsellor
i'm seeing a series of shaking heads
i'll give it a couple of seconds for
people to type if they want to have a
question or speak
cancer adam thank you just a quick one
um
how much consultation have you had from
the applicant
uh in relation to this not
much
okay that was short and sweet
okay that no one else has registered to
or sorry no one else else has indicated
they would like to ask you a question so
counselor thank you very much for your
i do apologize councillor crump came in
right at the last minute
counselor crum go ahead come mr chairman
i'd just like to ask where's the nearest
alternative
facilities um if those facilities were
not available
i i you know did you mentioned car usage
and obviously
um no well stratford would be
warwick uh both eight miles away
uh shirley also uh six miles away
um and to get to warwick from henley you
have to have a car
stratford we do have a bus service and a
train service but it's not
brilliant um and
it's hourly i should say rather not
brilliant and
the same to go to shirley um
the monies from
the sports center that warwickshire
college
are hoping to receive or have received
uh went
to uh morton morrill to
um build
or enhance their facility there and as i
said
that that is the replacement
for henley sports center and uh
it is almost impossible to get to by
public transport
thank you thank you very much
counselor thank you very much no one
else has indicated they wish to speak so
um thank you very much for your
contribution tonight i'm glad we uh we
did eventually managed to get to hear
from you
um i would suggest that you you again if
you could hang up the phone and continue
to watch
via the online portal i think that's
probably the best way to do it
lovely thank you very much indeed
marvelous thank you very much
and before i bring in our next speaker i
just reiterate to all speakers uh both
for this item and for future items
there is a mild delay on uh the um
uh the meeting being sent up to
either through youtube or through our
online portal
please do mute uh or turn off that
um that stream when you are speaking
it's enormously unnerving to hear my own
voice coming back at me
and i think frustrating for you for not
being able to speak so please do
remember to either mute or turn off the
live stream while you're speaking
our next speaker then um is mr stephen
vaughan who is the applicant mr vaughan
are you there can you hear me you may
need to press start and 6 on your keypad
you know in order for us to be able to
hear you
mr vaughn star and 6 will unmute you
i've just seen you and meet yourself can
you hear us
i can hear you can you hear me we can
you sound slightly distant
but we can hear you any better
a little bit yes um it's certainly
workable
now mr vaughn you you have six minutes
to speak
um by virtue of the fact that we have
had two speakers prior to you so six
minutes we'll give you a 30 second
warning
and again if you could stay on
afterwards to answer any questions that
would be great
and whenever you're ready please do
start thank you
um okay thank you for the opportunity to
address the committee tonight and share
with you
the definitive process behind the
application from from our perspective
um a very brief history of wasps for
those that aren't aware
it's a very long history having been a
founding member of the rugby
family since 1867 um obviously only
recently moving to the to the midlands
to coventry in 2015 and um
you know a fairly nomadic past but in in
every home
um that we've had um whether it be in
london or in the home counties um
we've had demonstrable um um
kind of um you know uh situations where
we've been an integral part of the
community and um
you know that's backed up in what we do
now already which i'll talk about in a
second
um like all premiership rugby team we
rely on community involvement which is a
driver for our
fan base for a link for local businesses
and and obviously
um also acts as a learning center for
our school age academy players
and professional players of the future
in terms of the purchase on the site
since 2015 we have been looking for a
sustainable training ground
in the catchment area for for our
community involvement
and last year we were fortunate to
conditionally purchase small parts
of the henley and arden site from the
warwickshire college group at that
time the whole site was failing as a
commercial venture due to a lack of
support and funding
with regards to the planning and
community use agreement we have involved
ourselves in the pre-planning and
planning process for our agents this
agreement with the lpa which reflects
our commitment to the local area
although we are nearly rugby club we
pride ourselves on our support of
grassroots sport
and our men's team women's team amateur
team
and netball team engaged with more than
20 000 children's
children and adults per year from
all manner of backgrounds via our
sporting school
charity and community programmes already
focusing on
four key pillars of what we do and those
four key pillars of education
employability
inclusion and development it's very much
what we do
with regards to grassroots and working
within the community
with regards to this application we've
initially committed to a number of open
training sessions
to show local people interested groups
what goes on behind the scenes
at an elite sports club and we really
look forward to this continuing
as an experience should we be successful
because experience has shown us that
these types of things and behind closed
doors
money can't buy activities for for local
people it
really doesn't generation to involve
themselves
in more sporting activity and also opens
their eyes to the wider opportunities
available
in sporting organisations outside of
just the plane group
our planned summer camps as well that
we're planning to hold locally are
extremely popular
and educational too and you know we
passionately believe that
the social and economic benefits to
henley and arden the wider community
will be significantly enhanced by our
local involvement
and our already established
community-based programmes
so that's it from me but happy to take
any questions
wonderful thank you mr vaughan members
if you could please indicate in a chat
if you would like to ask the applicant
any questions
i'll kick us off if i may you mentioned
um summer camps and
and a series of open days to see behind
the scenes
outside of that i'm aware from our
update sheet that you've entered
into a community use agreement how much
use
if any will the community be able to
have outside of your normal functioning
hours
yeah so if i just kind of talk through
what there is obviously
the use of the floodlight 3g pitch this
um this will be upgraded
um to a new surface um as well
um obviously use some car park changing
facilities as well within our within our
facility
for both obviously male and female and i
think we've talked about the
contribution so we're going to be making
a 50 000 pounds contribution
to the lpa as well for a support related
initiative in the area or initiatives
um as as it deems fit
um again we know we're going to be
looking to
engage people in what we do so we're
offering a thousand tickets for matches
for
the next decade um for schools colleges
and sports groups as well as the open
training sessions that we've just spoken
about
um summer camps and a wider community
program but the wider community program
will be something that we will have to
work closely with
the local groups sports clubs rugby
clubs um
so it doesn't necessarily mean you know
for example just
working with clever than rugby club
because they're local but you know a lot
of the things we do
at the moment could be around you know
education educating people around
you know diversity within uh within
areas or working with the bame
um groups or working with
school children with regards to you know
healthy eating and nutrition so
a real reach out sorry outreach campaign
within the local environment
so there are a number of um a number of
mr vaughn sir i don't i don't wish to
cut across you i i i wanted to hear
everything you've got to say
um everything you've said there is very
laudable um my specific question was
about community
use so um i'm guessing you mentioned the
rugby club presumably it's available for
rent by
uh the community or people who come and
use it outside of your normal working
hours that specifically was what i was
looking for rather than sorry
sorry i thought you wanted a more uh
broad brush yeah that's absolutely
correct so
um the facilities that we've highlighted
for example the the
the 3g pitch which i said will be
upgraded is um
will be available for for higher um by
the hour
outside of our already uh presented um
kind of hours of use um so yes we will
uh we will obviously be making that um
available to the local community okay
lovely thank you
i do have three other counselors
registered to speak say or to ask you a
question so counselor adam first of all
thank you um when i asked the
parish council how much involvement um
they had in the in the application
process they said not much can you
explain why that
uh why that's the case and why why that
was what i came back
um without trying to um sidestep the
question
i think that's possibly a question for
the for the joint polish council
and it was a very succinct answer but um
if i just give you my
um take on the joint parish council um
god i'll just shoot from the hip on this
one and i was in
uh dialogue with um a member of the uh
the joint parish council
uh we had email dialogue telephone
dialogue this was before lockdown that
the exact dates uh i don't have on me at
the moment but then
we also engaged in a uh a meeting
uh myself and roger bevin from uh
warwickshire college group
where um the gentleman's name escapes
and but i want to say ray
um his name will come to me in a second
but i just don't have it to hand
um facilitated a meeting with
the henley
sports center alliance um
and we we met with those gentlemen um
they clearly had a
specific agenda but we sat through that
meeting
and then after that meeting um i again
spoke to the gentleman ray from the
joint parish council who thanked us for
our time
and then from there we have um
effectively followed every process
protocol and principle with our agency
um with the local um planners um
and you know we followed everything to
the letter so
um there's certainly never been a time
that i've been asked
to engage more with the joint paris
council
um or ever had a request for a meeting
um
asked of me that has ever been turned
down so
as far as i can see there has been any
time that we've been reached out to
for conversation or comments um
we we we've offered that uh vr either
ourselves or another party so
i don't know how i think the answer is
not much is
is uh suggested but happy to
you know elaborate if anybody can give
me any more information but we we've
engaged
mr vaughan sorry sorry to interrupt you
again i i think you've answered the
question fully there so thank you very
much for that
i'm just very conscious of the time we
do have a packed agenda i don't want to
prevent you from
an opportunity to speak and answer the
questions in full um but if you could
please keep them a bit more concise that
would be very helpful for
for for all of us really um counselor
crump has a question for you as well if
he may please thank you
um yeah keep this brief obviously uh
20 000 grassroots contacts is is pretty
impressive
and that's laudable but 711 letters of
objections is also impressive too and it
shows you haven't won over the community
why do you think that
why do i think we have one of the
community um to try and keep it succinct
i don't know what i went over the
community i assume
that once um you know if we were to be
granted an application
i'm very confident that um you know
the the the the team the the the upgrade
of the facilities the outreach program
the um the the the players and and the
staff
involvement in the local community uh
would absolutely
to your wording win over people and i
will just say very briefly when we've
been
to henry and arden i've taken the squad
down twice to different locations for
food drink beverage
etc the welcome has been extremely warm
um
but um i'm not a resident of henley and
arden i know helen arden very well but i
can't answer the question as to why
um you know 711 people have decided to
to to to write against is what i can
tell you is i'm extremely confident that
if our application is successful um that
everywhere we've been so far we've been
plugged into the community an integral
part of it
and expect that to be the same fabulous
thank you and councilman mills has a
question
thanks mr chairman yes good evening um
on the lesser objection um
they said the um the pigeons won't be
available but you said yes they can have
one higher but
um just can you tell me the sports hall
in the gym
would they be excluded to the public
yes um so it's just the uh the 3g
pitch that is in uh is in scope at this
stage
the gymnasium is required um to
accommodate
offices as part of the cloning
application as well as the strength and
conditioning area which requires a
mezzanine floor level
restricted space yeah to answer your
question uh yeah that's correct it would
just be the
thank you thank you
lovely thank you and we have one last
very quick question i think from
councillor adam as well
thank you um it was just uh in relation
to where your base of operations for
what it is currently can you tell me
where that is
yes um so i worked on a training center
if you will
is at a broad street rugby club um which
is
um it's on the a46 um
kind of going out from the m6 uh out
towards
the kind of um just the kind of shapes
sorry the east side of coventry um area
okay thank you very much lovely thank
you
ever so much everyone um we have no one
else uh
asking questions or wanting to answer
questions so mr vaughan
thank you very much for your
contribution tonight it is greatly
appreciated again if you want to
hang up the phone now and continue to
watch on either the online portal or
through you
through youtube that would probably be
the best thing to do but thank you again
for for being here and contributing
many thanks thanks okay
um we now move to points of
clarification for our officers once
again members if you could please
indicate in
the meeting chat if you have a point of
clarification you would like to make
while you are doing that or deciding
whether you want to do that
um alison if you could uh please
do you know cancer dixon i've got it
thank you
i cannot apologize more
casa jennings you didn't appear on my
screen and i
completely overlooked you i do apologize
profusely
are you there do we have a video feed of
you or is it just are we just hearing
you you should have a
camera there you are you've popped up i
i cannot apologize enough
castle jennings you've got five minutes
and once again
a 30-second warning and if you could
stand for questions that'd be great
whenever you're ready thank you chairman
i'm
good evening and hopefully i won't take
up the full like allocation of time
right this is a privately owned sports
center which was open to the general
public
much like david lloyd's pure gym or
banana sports center
i have checked and rechecked and there's
no community ownership
or data covenant there is a community
use order
as one of the conditions of a previous
planning application
but that does not give any community
ownership
we do however have a community-owned
sports center
in henley um opposite the site
i think the parish may have forgotten
about that that's the henley war
memorial sports centre
which is in trust to the people of
henley this has a cricket pitch
football pictures tennis courts balls
courts
and a shooting range they also house the
lows called
scouts and have a clubhouse which
incidentally has planning for an
extension
but no funds i'm sorry i'm just doing my
sales pitch
because they're always on the lookout
for new members and funding
and they're openly looking for new new
children
for their sports and football teams um
but back to the warwickshire college
sports centre across the road
when the facility is used by the general
public be it a bank
shop or in this case a sports centre is
closed
there's always disappointment amongst
those that used it
and that's been closed for almost a year
now and i understand that the owners
have no intention of reopening it
whatever the outcome of this application
and i've said all along do i want
someone using the site
rather than just sitting empty for what
could be years to come
the parish council was split on this
planning application
there was a six to five vote it
certainly wasn't unanimous
and the parish also did a survey
recently
which has been mentioned which was sent
out to 3
000 people 486
ticked the box we may lose a significant
community sports based health
and fitness center 108
tick the box i believe the wasps will
bring jobs revenue and prestige
2404 didn't reply
which could be seen as significant or
interesting
however this survey um did not raise or
discuss
any material planning matters and i have
to put it quite brutally
um you're not here to determine or judge
a popularity contest
getting involved in private commercial
transactions is outside the arena to the
stratfor district councillor
we have no special to powers to
determine who owns it
how they sell it how it is run or what
is used for
as long as it's gone through the correct
legal and planning channels in order to
do this
as planning and committee members you
are here purely to judge this
application on material planning matters
this application is quite
straightforward as it has no building
work there's no encroachment on the
green belt
no changes to highways no trees being
cut down
all of which take away a lot of the
subjective decisions
this proposal sir certainly seems to
meet cs22 economic development
requirements
so this is all about change of use and
fulfilling the criteria in order to
achieve this
and this takes us back to our bible
is called course strategy
if you go on to page 207 of the course
strategy policy cs25
and i'll read this to you as quickly as
i can
it is expected that existing community
facilities such as shops
pubs medical and leisure will be
retained unless it can be determined
that one or more of the following
criteria is satisfied
that's one that which they need to do
there is no real
realistic prospect of the facility
continuing for commercial
and or operational reasons on that site
two the land or property is being
actively marketed
or otherwise made available for a
similar
or alternative types of facility
there'll be a benefit to the community
three the facilities
the facility can be provided effectively
in an alternative matter
on a different site in accordance with
the wishes of the local community
and for there are overriding
environmental benefits which is not
applicable
if you feel that the applicant has not
met
any of the four then obviously you'd
refuse it
but if you feel that the applicant has
met one out of the
four then you have no option but to go
along with the officer's decision to
grant
but the ball is in your court
council jennings thank you very much uh
members do we have any questions for our
war member
please indicate in the chat if you do
i'm seeing a bunch of shaking heads
counselor jennings i think you're you're
free of questions thank you once again
for your contribution this evening
um uh we will now move on feel free to
continue watching of course but we will
now move on
to our points of clarification where we
very nearly got taken earlier
um members if you want to indicate again
in the chat if you have a point of
clarification
allison i do have one um i i mentioned
about the evidence
um for uh the marketing
um i can see on again on page 18 of the
report
um you've detailed there that we the
the the land was um uh marketed for
approximately three years by bromish
hardy
um have you seen the actual evidence for
that i'm assuming you have
uh the the the speaker the objective
insinuated that perhaps it hadn't been
done can you just confirm for my own
sake whether you have seen it and that
evidence
exists uh thank you mr chairman i've had
direct
conversations with the
financial officer from warwickshire
college group and
emails from him on the subject
okay thank you um we have a question
also for clarification from councillor
dixon councillor dixon
thank you chairman a question for the
planners
um sport england holding objection
pending receipts of further information
listed there is the community use
agreement with the council
we know from our update sheet that the
community use agreement has been
approved under condition 2 etc
question is can sport england require
that to be more extensive
than simply the use of the 3g pitch does
their holding
objection still apply if we were minded
to grant permission this evening
thank you chairman
the uh sport england holding objections
on the basis
uh i clarified this with sport england
it's on the update sheet that they're
the holding objection is on the basis
that the use of the
3g existing 2g pitch
which is used for hockey currently is
prejudiced by this application so
um so they're holding on objection is
not um that's the only reason that
that that the application would be
triggered
for referral to the secretary of state
state they have expressed concern about
the loss of the sports hall
and we've been in continual discussion
about the contents of the community use
agreement
and indeed the community use agreement
has been modified
to include some of their requirements
so in truth on that one through you
chairman
obviously sport england sounds to me as
though they're holding objection
remains because of the uh not in the
replacement of the hockey pitch
yes it's because it's not a light for
like replacement it's uh
it's being upgraded from a 2g pitch to a
3g pitch
which we would be suitable for a
different range of
sports not including hockey
lovely stuff thank you very much and we
have a question from counselor adam as
well please
answer adam thank you chairman um it was
something i can't remember which speaker
mentioned it
one of the first two um in regards to
conditions attached to the existing
condition that led to the current
facility being built
um are you able to elaborate on what if
any of there might be outstanding in
relation to that and the community use
outside of the
um community use agreement with the
council
so the existing community use agreement
dating back to 2007
relates to the internal facilities only
so and the the community use agreement
enabled evening and weekend use of the
internal facilities but it didn't cover
the external pictures
so the replacement community use
agreement again
covers evenings and evenings and
weekends and holiday periods
but obviously it doesn't include the
sports or but it does secure
the use of the external pictures
so it's an alternative
okay i think that's uh that answers the
question um
i see no other uh indication of uh point
of clarification so members let's move
straight to the debate
who would like to start us off
dance will jump at once
council mills why not
why not thank thanks ms jim yeah um
yes as you know i i do look he's going
about
my own site visit um i actually went to
the entrance you're not supposed to go
to and uh drove back
almost around to the back of the site
and also went to the other side as uh
entrance as well and who thought at the
time what a waste
of um of a facility and um
to be honest to think this is now being
taken up again i
i i could think you'd only be good for
the for the community
um and the fact that they're offering 50
000
pounds to to the community um
we just spend where they will and they
have do have a sports
facility opposite this um
sports ground um i'm
buying blinded to go with the officer's
recommendation mr chairman thank you
thank you counselor is that a form of
proposal uh to go with the officer's
recommendation
can i put there's a proposal there mr
chairman thank you you can i will accept
that as a proposal
uh counselor kendall please
thank you chairman and i'm happy to
second uh the proposal um i've listened
very carefully to everything look i
understand the community
don't always like change i get that but
i think council jennings spoke
incredibly well and he said everything
that i was thinking
all the way through the presentation i
was thinking exactly what he was saying
about
um how this isn't for us to get involved
with it's it may not be what we all love
but actually i think it's quite a good
plan considering
as councilman correctly says it's a bit
of a mess at the moment
it brings the site back into use it's
going to be overall i think good for the
community so
i've said enough on the matter so i'm
happy to second
thank you very much casa kendall anyone
else would like to make their
their views known at this stage if not
we can start to move towards a vote
counselor adam thank you um
i'm slightly intrigued um i know there's
a lot of
heartfelt feeling behind this um most
primary
primarily appears to be the loss of
facility um which i know is also
substantiated somewhat by sports england
50 000 pounds is not an insubstantial
amount of money
and i'm wondering to what extent we are
able
um through conditions to ensure that
that is um
you put to put to the use to ensure that
the
you know the potential detriment that
this might
have to the community can be uh
rectified let's say
um i mean how how far can we go i know
section 106 is
um fairly fairly broad sometimes but
is that something that officers can
elaborate on or is that something that
you might keep the question i think i
can answer that for you cancer adam and
if you look on page 23
of your um report um
you may well have missed the notes at
the bottom specifically there is a note
that says 50 000 pounds to be
contributed to an
alternative sports facility which is to
be agreed with the joint parish council
so it puts the power
with the parish council um i don't think
we can go further than that and i
wouldn't support anything that would go
further than that
personally i just missed that note but
thank you very much
no problem um council fleming please
yeah thank you mr chairman um
uh councillor jennings was saying that
uh they already have plans to build an
extension to their clubhouse over the
road which would house a gym
but they have no money this gives them
an ideal opportunity to actually get
some money
uh to do that and it would also give
them the opportunity to when we put the
hockey pitch over the road
um which would take away two of the
major objections to all of this
um so like you say although we are not
in a position to determine that
there are they are making provisions
that uh
that could help out the community to to
retrieve some of the things they'll lose
lovely thank you very much um i can see
no one else registered to speak
um i'll just very quickly uh give my
view um and that is very much
in line with council mills and
councillor kendall i thought council
jennings spoke extraordinary well and
and some
summarized the points the key points um
uh
that we needed to that needs to be drawn
out really um one thing that we haven't
really focused on is the economic
benefit that comes with
a professional sports outfit to the
immediate surrounding area
particularly in a time where uh business
of businesses have been forced to close
rugby is very much back on the agenda um
that it is being played and there is a
huge economic benefit to having
such a professional outfit there so um i
can see no real
material planning reason to go against
the officer's recommendation
our planning manager would like to have
a quick word before we move to a vote so
if i can call in
uh dale barker before we do that thank
you chair yeah i do apologize for this
um under normal circumstances i would be
having a quick word with
the council solicitor while members were
speaking but unfortunately
that's not possible in this type of
meeting could i ask you chair
to um pause the meeting for a few
moments while i have a quick word with
the council solicitor
in the um in the private meeting before
you go on to take the vote
and i'll explain why once i've spoken to
him
your your muted chair i do apologize um
i'm happy to do that is it right and
proper that i join you in that so i know
what the discussion is or is does this
need to be done
there's absolutely no problem with that
torture okay um
we will just adjourn for a couple of
seconds or a minute probably while we
have that discussion
i think we're all back right chairman i
don't
think you heard any of that discussion
did you um unfortunately not no i think
um somehow my screen
uh well i don't know what happened with
teams there was a technical problem if
you would kindly share with
um so we're all versed in what's
happening well it's very simple
um once allison had written this report
i
edited it and clearly i made
an error in that editing and don't worry
the the error is only in the
recommendation and it's easily corrected
if you look at the end of the sports
england comment i'm sorry i don't know
what page it is on your report because
mine isn't numbered
it says should the local planning
authority be minded to grant planning
permission
in accordance with the town country
planning consultation england direction
the application should be referred to
the secretary of state via the national
planning casework unit
so our recommendation should have been
and was until i
mistakenly omitted it is to recommend
approval
as it stands subject to the prior
completion of the section 106 obligation
and subject to the views of the national
planning case work unit
we are obliged to refer it to them
nothing else in the discussion that
we've had changes in any way chairman
okay that's that's absolutely fine um i
apologize for you we understood that to
be the case
by virtue of the the information that
was contained in the update sheet
um but i'll just double check uh
councilman mills you made the
um the original proposal you're entirely
happy with the wording as indicated by
councillor barca
councillor sorry i've been promoted
um yes mr chairman yes that's no problem
i'm fine with that thank you thank you
and council kendall yes i'm fine as well
thank you chairman
marvelous okay in that case we can move
to a vote
so um uh the proposal has been to
uh grant in line with his office's
recommendation as detailed in the
conversation we've just had now
um i will go first councillor richards
four
thank you councillor planning council
fleming for
councillor kendall councillor kendall
four
councillor adam councillor adam
paul councillor cramp
cancer crumpfort councillor dixon
councillor dixon four council vehement
councillor andrew serafin four and
councillor mills
council bills for that's unanimous chair
fabulous thank you and thank you members
uh committee therefore resolves to grant
application number twenty zero zero zero
six six ful for henley and arden sports
club in line with the officer's
recommendation
um and including uh the wording about
the national planning
casework unit as uh we have agreed
fabulous members thank you so much um
could i check with our democratic
services that we do
have all our speakers ready to go for
our next application
they are our chair yes fabulous in that
case we won't adjourn we will move
straight to it
so this application uh application
number five
is application reference nineteen zero
one 113 ful
that's kelsteen barton road in
welthordon haven
our presenting officer is alison willis
alison
over to you
thank you mr chairman i'm just sharing
my screen
with you hopefully i think it's just
loading
hopefully you can see that yet we can
indeed yes thank you
okay so um
this housing site is on the south side
of welford on avon
location as shown by the black dot
it doesn't seem to be progressing um
just turn it off and we share it
sorry about that um this is
an application for the demolition of an
existing dwelling called calstein
where the yellow dot is
here and associated outbuildings to the
south
and the for the erection of 24 dwellings
the proposals include
associated access improvements public
open space
sustainable drainage and landscaping
here is a recent aerial view of the site
showing the application site outlined in
red
it's made up of existing dwelling
kelsteen and three fields
neighboring residential development on
barton fields to the north
north west north east long marston road
badges close and elizabeth close to the
east and samantha close to the south of
the site
the caravan park is situated to the
south west of the site
and newly constructed dwellings above
the site to the west and southeast
the site lies well within the built-up
area boundary for welford on
avon which is the local category 2 local
service village
so this is the proposed layout kalsteen
and the outbuilding is demolished with
new dwellings
in its place accessed from the main road
here access to the other dwellings is
created by extending the existing
hammerhead at the end of barton fields
cul-de-sac
here barton road would be widened
and the visibility at the junction would
be improved
24 new houses six four beds
three seven three beds ten two beds
and one one bed including eight
bungalows
identified with the pink dots that's
there there
there there there there
there and there and the proposals also
include
eight affordable houses with a tenure
profile comprising of
five social rent and three shadow
ownership
marked by the red stars
there's a play area suds five visit
parking spaces
electric vehicle charging points and
secure cycle storage
this is the landscaping plan showing the
retained vegetation in dark green
around the perimeter and new native
trees and shrubs represented by
lighter greens the section 106 planning
obligation will
secure a range of infrastructure
and biodiversity requests as detailed in
the officer report
and the development would also attract
still payment
so this slider illustrates the housing
the materials and the types and looking
east and west from the central spine
road
[Music]
so this is a photo montage taken from
within the site at the top looking north
towards kellstein and barton fields
cul-de-sac and at the bottom
looking towards the southeast corner
so this slide shows the house that would
be demolished
this is barton fields cul-de-sac
and this is the end of barton fields
cul-de-sac where the access will be
created
thank you mr chairman that's the end of
the presentation there are two
updates as per the update sheet mr
chairman the recommendation is that the
application be granted
subject to conditions and notes and
subject to the completion of a section
106 legal
agreement as outlined in the report for
the reasons detailed in the report
the wording and numbering of which is
delegated to officers
thank you very much fantastic thank you
very much alison
um we will move straight to our first
speaker who is councillor carter from
welford parish council
councillor carter are you there you may
need to press star and sex to unmute
yourself
yes can you hear me we can indeed
welcome
good evening excellent i've done this
before i know
um but you have three minutes we'll give
you a 30 second warning um
and then please down the line four
questions afterwards whenever you're
ready please do
begin okay thank you um good evening
councillors um
we're actually very disappointed to be
here tonight because we've worked really
well with the applicant to achieve some
good results on this development and
there's a good housing mix
um we've got a whole site plan rather
than we're going to get it piecemeal
before
but the access to this site is a real
issue
for the people involved in in barton
fields and
with a bit more work we could have done
a lot better
we do have a policy actually that says
more should be done and that's
neighborhood development plan policy
hlu5
which state states that um if there's a
detrimental
effect on neighboring properties then
that is in fact a good reason to
um uh refuse an application and clearly
this one
um you know is a fight it's a small five
cul-de-sac
um five house police sack in barton
fields
and it's going to turn into a very busy
link road
warrior county highways say that it's
okay
after some deliberation um but we've had
an independent
or the um the residence who had an
independent traffic consultant who's
actually um worked out that that
condition cannot be met
without uh compulsory purchasing it
adjacent to residential land
so we believe this does need a bit more
work um
ndp policy hlu1 also says
that if a development is going to
generate significance amount of traffic
which this one clearly will
um there should be they should be sort
of demonstrate how they're going to
alleviate those those issues there is a
safe
simple and alternative access to this
which would combine
uh kelsteen and barton fields and barton
fields wouldn't be accessed from barton
road it would come off the new
development
and we would ask that you refuse this
application and we work
up this alternative access which
actually would solve
that you know major problem there are
other issues of course that concern us
and when you look at you know your own
preferred option
site allocation plan welford in effect
it says has done its bit
um we're actually we only have two sites
now in this one rather than four last
time
and we're in tier seven so the last to
be called upon
so there is a bit of a question about
why do we need another 24 now
um welford's actually done its bit we've
done we've got 117 houses within the
built-in area boundary
against our 84 and 167 in total
and of course actually sdc has a land
supply in excess of 200 percent
um the other real issue for us is about
infrastructure and sewage
you will recall earlier last
earlier this year we had raw sewage
flowing onto the streets in four
areas and only last week we had a 96
year old lady in
21 samantha close who had to get out of
their house because
the toilets were overflowing with sewage
so we've got real issues we need
infrastructure
investment before we get more housing
so on this basis i'd ask the committee
to reject this application
um and work with the pc we will come up
with a solution here
you know we need to work together to
achieve a better result than we're
getting at the moment
thank you lovely thank you very much
councillor carter
members do uh any of you have any
questions for councillor carter
councillor crum thank you mr chairman
good evening councillor carter just a
couple of brief ones first
firstly about the independent traffic
consultant
that the uh the residents brought up
and has that information have has the
consultant or the residents
or the parish council made that evidence
available to the highways authority
um as far as i'm aware the answer to
that is yes they have
and i think the um the independent
consultant did actually submit that
information
um over the last day or two
thank you and again um
some information and again if there is a
response from from 710 that would be
great
you mentioned the flooding and so the
sewerage and
obviously that must be terrible um a
double whammy at times
um have you approached seven trent with
your concerns as well
about those and have laughed at any any
remedy
um especially brings an extra
potentially 24 properties
um um yes so we've had long we've had
quite a lot of deliberation with
um seven trent and seven trent we're
going to do a full survey of our sewer
network
um and they said they were going to
share that with us but they haven't done
to date and in fact this application was
held up for quite some time because
seven trent um had an objection
against it because of the infrastructure
limitations
now to a certain extent as we stand
today we do we've not seen the survey
from seven trends
and we do know we've got an engineer who
lives close to this who
actually has done a very good piece of
work um highlighting the you know
all of long marston road which now
includes another development that we
agreed to
with um spitfire around the corner it's
got 200 houses
um feeding into it it's got 9 000 square
meters of
um of surface water going into it it's a
six inch pipe
we actually believe some of the
developments that have already gone in
at
samantha close and some of the others
should have timed
discharges into the main into that
six-inch pipe but clearly they're not
doing that and that's the reason why
we had the problem that samantha close
um so
we you know i'm absolutely convinced
that if we have a lot more rain like we
had
earlier in the year we will have similar
sewage issues in welford
and is all we're asking for is a bit of
investment we haven't had any
to date and uh we need some investment
in our
sewer network uh before we get you know
another 24 houses
which is quite a big development for um
for welford
thank you casa yeah with my local order
we have
um quite similar issues with seven trend
and response times not always the best
shall we say
but yeah thank you for that and it was
one one positive was that you were happy
with the housing mix because i thought
that was quite cool
absolutely we've done quite good work i
mean
debate which i'd rather avoid until we
actually get to the debate i can't fault
his enthusiasm
and i wouldn't want to sign me that but
uh we do have to do it at the right time
we do have another question please um
from councilman mills
so councillor mills yeah thank you
chairman in fact um
councilman has um asked a couple of
questions i want to ask but
just one other thing um where are you
considering this
other entrance um apart from button
fields
so i can't call up the map again but if
you look at the map you'll see the
kelsteen house is going to be demolished
so there's going to be a new house put
on there
yes what we've um we've sort of argued
is that
if you made a combined entrance for
kelsteen
the new house and the new development
and then had a
tee off on the left-hand side and in
effect where
i think there might have been an arrow
on one of the diagrams showing
uh the access to the new development
through barton fields
if you reverse the arrow and then closed
off the entrance
the existing barton fields entrance
actually
um barton fields would be fine it would
be accessed through
this new uh access for kellstein the new
development and barton field so to be a
um you know a a single entrance for all
of them
right thank you very much today let's
answer my question thank you
okay thank you thank you councillor
carter um no one else has indicated
they would like to ask you a question so
uh thank you very much for for joining
us and your contribution this evening
again if you'd like to uh
hang up the phone and then um continue
to watch
the online stream that's probably the
best way to to do things but thank you
again thank you very much indeed
everybody
marvelous okay um we will move
then now to our second speaker in fact
we have two registered speakers we have
a mr chapman and
ms grundy are you both there
um if you could press star on six on
your keeper yeah
yeah i'm here but a vet was speaking
first yeah hello
hi yvette um do you mind if i call you a
vet rather than mr andy
no i prefer that that's better thank you
it's no problem at all
um yvette um i understand you're
speaking first um will you
be speaking for uh a specific amount of
time or are you going to speak and then
uh mr chapman's going to take over we've
liaised
and as closely as possible i'll be
speaking for approximately one minute
and mr chapman will be speaking for
approximately two
okay do you want us to give you any time
warning as you're approaching your
minute or should we let you flow through
and then we'll just give a 30-second
warning for mr chapman when he gets to
i've been practicing it is about a
minute yes okay
uh no problem at all in that case
whenever you're ready please do begin
thank you behalf of the residents of
barton fields
i urge you to refuse planning permission
due to the permanent
detrimental impact that this proposal
will have
on our community to approve this current
plan
would metaphorically and literally drive
a bulldozer
through a previous piece of excellent
planning the effectiveness of which
has been proved through the healthy and
the thriving community that's evolved in
barton fields
in the 40-plus years since it was built
lack of engagement with those of us who
will be most affected by the current
proposals
has resulted in a plan that will cause
lasting and permanent damage to our
community
whereas consultation and considerable
consideration of alternatives
such as access through the kelsteen plot
and positioning bungalows rather than
two-story houses behind
existing gardens could have resulted in
a safer
and a much less damaging outcome please
don't negate the positive
community impact of a previous high
quality planning decision
by now approving an application with
destructive
social implications please protect our
local community
by protecting the currently safe
community space that joins us
david chapman whose presentation follows
will address in more detail on our
behalf
why local road safety will be seriously
and permanently compromised by
this application thank you
mr chairman start whenever you're ready
yeah
there's supposed to be six slides with
my okay so slide one um
the proposals would lead to severely
restricting the unsafe visibility from
the driveway of five bathroom fields
onto the new access road
the applicant has shown this visibility
on their master plan and drawings
produced in september
however these slaves are shown through
land within the ownership of five
dartmouth fields
relying on this third-party land is
neither suitable nor appropriate
apex sorry slide two apex have measured
the driveway visibility
using the appropriate constraint point
with visibility just 12 to 15 meters
equating to speeds of 10 to 30 miles per
hour
these are lower than shown by the
applicant as their reliance on land
outside of their control to demonstrate
their displays
the applicant was required to provide
driving visibility within the site at 25
meters for 20 miles per hour design
speed
the visibility from 5000 fields would be
significantly below this level
which is not acceptable the highway
authority also recognized that
the existing driveway is in close
proximity to the bend on the new
carriageway
there is no evidence showing that
suitable visibility can be achieved
slide three at the barton road junction
vehicles park regularly parked within
the envelope of visibility both on the
street
and on the verge this severely restricts
visibility particularly to the east
given the intensification and use this
is a potential road safety issue which
has not been considered
slide four
between the sky entrance and plot 10
there are just three locations where a
car can pass a refuge vehicle this could
lead to reversing on the highway and
conflicts between vehicles and
pedestrians
in slide side conflicts between vehicles
from three and four bars and fields and
site traffic have not been considered
there is the potential for rear-end
chunk collisions involving vehicles
reversing to and from driveways
on slide six just showing the access
from the existing kelsey driveway
this could be more appropriate than the
unsuitable and unsafe access being
proposed
so in summary the proposals do not allow
for safe and suitable access they have
an unacceptable impact on highway safety
and appropriate modifications not being
provided the proposals are contrary to
the mppf and core strategy
at cs26 we respect the request that
planning commissioners refused on
highway safety grounds
thank you marvelous mr chairman thank
you very much you were marginally over
but i i'm willing to allow that given
night i spoke as you were about to begin
um okay members do you have any
questions for either of our speakers
please indicate in the chat if you do
i'm seeing nothing coming up but i will
give it a couple more seconds just to
see if
we get someone typing
that looks like a no so um yvette mr
chapman
thank you very much for your
contribution tonight uh once again if
you want to continue watching
uh through the online portal that would
probably be the best thing to do and to
hang up your phones now
um so we can continue but thank you
again for your contribution
thank you marvelous
okay we can now move to our agent who
is liz nicholson uh liz you have done
this before
star six to unmute yourself uh hopefully
we'll be able to hear you
hello chair can you hear me we can
indeed welcome good evening
um i'm just gonna check that i give you
the right time i think you have six
minutes you
do so you've got six minutes feel free
to use as much or as little as it as you
wish
um uh we'll give you a thirty second
warning and whenever you're ready please
feel free to commence thank you good
evening councillors
rosscon strategic land have worked hard
with your officers to design
a high quality scheme that meets all
policy requirements and addresses all
technical points raised by consultees
a series of amended plans have been
provided to address concerns raised by
officers
they have also endeavoured to engage
with the local community having attended
two parish council meetings before the
formal application was submitted
and maintained an ongoing dialogue with
them since and having had direct
dialogue with two of the residents in
barton fields
given the time available i've focused on
a small number of key points and i'm
happy to answer questions on these or
other matters if that assists
whilst we're aware of the concerns
expressed regarding housing numbers in
welfare during the planned period
your own recently published preferred
options site allocations plan says this
it is important to remember that the
core strategy does not restrict
additional housing in any or all
circumstances
and there are a number of instances
where proposals for additional homes
will be policy compliant
and therefore granted planning consent
in summary these include within the
built-up area of the main town
a main rural centre or a local service
village in accordance with policy cs16
this statement clearly applies to the
scheme before you tonight
further supported by a made neighborhood
development plan
that supports new housing development
within the built-up area boundary
there are no technical grounds on which
to refuse this application
drainage has been a key local concern
and it is important to recognize that
foul water from this scheme will be sent
into the public sewer in barton road
which is not a sewer that connects to
the sewer in the pool close area where
there were previous overflow problems
surface water will be discharged at a
controlled rate into the adjacent
watercourse
biodiversity has also been raised as a
concern an ecological habitat area will
be combined with the on-site attenuation
pond
works will be carried out to manage and
enhance existing boundary hedges
and a detailed landscaping scheme for
the whole site proposes new tree hedge
and wetland planting
on top of this it has been agreed with
the county ecologist that biodiversity
credits for a sum of about 150 000
pounds will be made to the scheme of old
scottish state
we know you've heard tonight that the
proposed extension of the
existing road into barton fields has
raised a lot of concerns
but to put this in context i'd like to
remind the committee of four examples of
recent schemes in the district which
have been approved which extended an
existing cul-de-sac
they're on the screen in front of you
top left is
a site in bidford you can see the
existing cul-de-sac in
the top part of that image and a scheme
of 14 dwelling 40 dwellings was approved
there which you can see
top right is a scheme of thousand you
can see the cul-de-sac as it was
existing
before the scheme in the bottom part of
that image and
51 dwellings were approved linked to
that existing cul-de-sac
bottom left is a scheme in bidford and
that scheme was for nine dwellings and
again you can see the previous
cul-de-sac in the bottom part of the
image
and then the proposed development well
the approved development
in the top part and finally a scheme of
any comps and it's the same where you
have an existing cul-de-sac and an
extension
to that cul-de-sac which approved four
dwellings
in none of those cases were highway
safety or neighbour amenity considered
to be defensible reasons for refusal
whilst all applications must be
determined on their merits there can be
no objection to the principle of
extending the road at barton fields
there would need to be evidence of
site-specific reasons why this would
cause unacceptable harm
whilst the officer report states that a
new alternative access through the
kellstein
top seems like a reasonable alternative
these comments appear to have been made
without advice from your highways
officers
and it is important to remember that the
decision maker cannot look at
alternative proposals unless there is
evidenced harm
caused by the scheme in front of them
again the applicant has worked hard with
your officers to ensure that the access
meets adopted standards and is safe for
road users
as demonstrated by the submitted road
safety audit
as a result the highways officer raises
no objections from a highway safety
perspective
with regards to the immunity space on
the corner of barton road and barton
fields this land is highways verge the
majority of which will be retained in
addition a significant new area of
public open space will be created less
than 50 metres into the new development
for both new and existing residents to
enjoy
finally with regards to climate change
your council's checklist has been
completed and submitted
bringing together a lot of information
to demonstrate that this development
provides a great number of the local and
national policy requirements
the section 106 agreement and the
conditions proposed will secure these
requirements
covering matters such as water birth
cycle storage
superfast broadband pedestrian
accessibility and safety
electric vehicle charging points
drainage infrastructure
sustainable construction and financial
contributions
to local physical and social
infrastructure improvements
in conclusion we would ask that this
development be supported
thank you chair thank you very much liz
um members do we have any questions for
the applicant's agent
please indicate in the chat if you do
i'm seeing a few shaking heads
we'll give it a couple of seconds
i'm going to take that as a no in that
case so liz thank you so much for your
contribution this evening once again if
you want to continue watching on the
online portal that would be the best way
to do it
okay thank you thanks okay
uh we can move now to our ward member
councillor pertiguella good evening
you are muted at the moment um but while
you want to meet yourself i will just
say that you have
five minutes to speak we will give you a
30-second warning
um and again we will be here to answer
questions afterwards
i've sent a powerpoint presentation it's
very important
thank thank you very much
committee members the residents of
barton fields would be
long-term impacted by this development
were never consulted by the applicant
this is contrary to the spirit of the
mppf which actively promotes the right
to local communities to shape the future
of their area
indeed this very right is embodied in
the welfare donation ndp
its hl u5 policy states that gardens and
backland development will only be
supported
if the development does not have a
detrimental effect on the surrounding
area
and neighboring properties and if the
development does not have the potential
for loss of amenity
of neighboring properties further bore
core strategy policies 9 and 20 say the
occupants of neighboring buildings will
be protected from an acceptable level
of noise contamination and pollution
loss of daylight and privacy and adverse
surroundings
so let me tell you how the adverse
impact to current
residents will be permanent and
irreversible
because of the insistence of the
applicant to use barton fields as the
access road
for the new development existing
dwelling in barton fields are designed
and laid out specially for a small
cul-de-sac
they kill the sack road can in fact be
considered as a single truck road
and see slide number two please the
proposed
through access road will bring a loss of
the sense of place for the small
community
as a small cul-de-sac barton fields is a
tranquil place
and current residents appreciate its
tranquility value
tranquility according to the stratfor
donavan district landscape sensitivity
assessment 2002
is a measure of landscape sensitivity
and is a valuable commodity
the proposed development will compromise
this measure
with a substantial increase in the
amount of vehicle movements through
barton fields
with associated air pollution and noise
with an average of two cars per
household
up to 50 cars delivery vans visitor cars
and other traffic
will contribute to the loss of
tranquility headlights from cars will
shine directly into the living space
windows of number four and number five
the passing traffic will be very close
to number five
and number one will also be subject to
an unacceptable disturbance from traffic
on barton road
as we have heard and you can see slider
three please
with regards to number 5 barton fields
while the new development provides
visitors parking spaces
and off-street parking the current
barton fields residents will lose
off-street parking for their own
visitors
there is another important loss of
amenity which accompanies this
application
while the new development offers green
space to future occupiers
the barton fields residents will lose
their green amenity space to the
widening of the access road and to the 2
meter footway
this open green space was integral part
of the barton field landscape design
and is shown on slide number four it
comprises a large grass verge and mature
edge rose as well as the dense ground
vegetation and has been used
as an amenity and community space and is
lovingly maintained
by the residents children play on this
area elderly residents enjoy the shade
in the summer months
families socialize and pick blackberries
in the late summer
the hedgerow and trees provide habitat
for insects and several species of birds
visit and nest in the trees
more recently during the pandemic the
green spaces allow residents to
socialize to still interact socially
distant
the amenity spaces for an importantly
space
for residents and a green corridor for
wildlife on the barton road and should
be preserved
in its entirety the part 5 climate
change adaptation and mitigation sdp
clearly encourages green buffer
and wildlife nodes at road junctions and
street corners
as the parish council has explained
there are alternatives to the access
road
you can see the ample frontage of
kelston in the final slide
there is enough space for the
development to have its own access from
the kalkstein ground
further in relation to he9 flood risk of
the
neighborhood development plan the
villages suffered incidents of sewage
flooding
on roads and unfortunately in homes and
another serious incident
happened just last week in the vicinity
in samantha claus we have not seen any
evidence
that the serious infrastructure problems
with sewage capacity in welford have not
been satisfactory resolved
putting another foul water drainage
pumping station
as the applicant is proposing will not
solve the problem of capacity
finally with regards to policy hlu1 this
would be the largest development in the
village
since 2013 and is therefore in the
context of its locality and over village
not a small development
the examples shown by the agent cannot
be compared
for example the jackson's made of in
bitford it's before does its
own plan and topography a main rural
center
so committee members um any adverse
impact will significantly and
demonstrably
outweigh the benefits i therefore
respectfully ask you that the
application is refused
thank you council person
thank you very much for that members do
you have any questions for the ward
member
please please indicate in the chat if
you do i'm seeing some shaking hits
i think councilman mills might have one
he seems to be typing
counselor mills
gosh you can see my every move then
chairman my word
um and by that the um the piece of the
meaning
amenity ground there energy ground um
that's always been maintained by the
residents has it
yes um it was is it belongs to obviously
worrisor county council but it's been
always maintained and lovely maintained
by the residents
so washington county council has never
come along cut the grass or
it's my understanding that the event is
is maintained by the residents
okay thank you and councillor crum
hi just very very good evening um nice
to see you
um just very briefly i i was listening
very carefully to
your speech as well as counselor carter
from paris council
um and he seemed to bear on on two
issues really
basically the um
the sewage and and the highways um
he seemed to didn't seem to have uh the
mix seemed to be acceptable
especially with eight bongros i think
and um and he didn't make particularly
comments about
the size i just wondered why you thought
the size in the mix
was potentially an issue when when the
parish council wasn't
raising that point i've noticed in the
point of the housing mix um
in fact i think in my representations in
my various representations of the
various revised plans i think i always
said that the housing mix
um is fine um we because obviously
well at the moment um he has um
affordable housing and um uh
bungalows as well it's it's what
the the the officer and the applicant
both said that this is a very small
development
and i wanted to say that it's not a
small development
in the context of this yeah no that's
fine yeah that's fine yeah thank you
yeah no that's that's that's explained
that lovely thank you
yeah i've got your point there thank you
thank you councillor
um members do we have anyone else that
would like to ask our award member a
question
there is no one in the chat um i'm
seeing a few people shaking heads
no okay council bears gallop thank you
very much
uh we will move on to our next uh
element which is
clarification of points to officers do
we have any points for clarification
again members please in the chat if you
would
i'm not seeing a huge amount of movement
some shaking of heads counselor adam
thank you chairman it's hopefully a
quick one um i think it lose to a
question to
the parish council i think earlier um
it was referenced that there was an
independent traffic survey
um that was carried out was that
information passed over to you
i know that that that was said that it
happened but um
from your point of view uh thank you
council adam um
yes the independent traffic uh
consultant's report was submitted to the
local authority
i then um passed it
back to the agent who passed it back to
their transport consultants
and also it was passed back to
warwickshire county council
all of whom have uh that the applicant's
transport consultant responded to that
his response was also sent to the county
council and the county council
have reviewed both documents and um
and finalized the discussion
by um not raising any concern
so everyone's talking to each other
thanks very much yeah
lovely thank you does anyone else have a
question they would like to raise with
our officer before we move to the debate
councillor mills
thanks for joining yes i was thinking
about this this um
independent traffic uh survey um
it is it's probably a question to john i
suppose
it was it was sent away to county
council
they've seen it and did um did you say
allison that
they had no objection to it or didn't
make any comment on it or what was it
um they reviewed the contents but they
they don't think there's any
reason for an objection
um did they not give any reasons
um well they'd say well yeah this
the application is not correct or no
the applicant's agent responded to all
the points
and i think highways authority agreed
with the
agent's uh transport consultant
okay i can see that um john probably
would like to
describe that council mills yeah i
wonder for the benefit of the public we
do have a traffic
sorry a highway wcc that's which county
council highways
um officer uh on the line with us um uh
john
i'm gonna not try and pronounce your
surname because i will embarrass myself
so apologies john
um john would you want to make a comment
at this point
uh yes so um when the
independent um independent report was
sent in
it was sent over to us and
basically our immediate comment was
this is for the applicants to to kind of
deal with rather than us it's for them
to kind of justify their their
development
and their their transport consultant
provided a
um a response to that which was
comprehensive really it addressed all of
the issues
um and we we felt there were no
outstanding issues
dealing with but if you have any
concerns about any of the
individual issues raised then i can
answer those questions as well
okay thank you so just for clarity
despite the um
the report that was put forward and what
we've just heard warwickshire county
council the highways authority maintain
its no objection stance
that's right objective conditions is
yeah okay that's helpful thank you um
counselor mills are you satisfied
that that has answered your question um
would you do you have any details no no
no mr chairman yeah
sorry i'm fine with that thank you mr
chairman thank you
lovely thank you um i'm i'm not seeing
any further comments in chats but
members if you want any more clarity
from
from either from our highway officer or
from from our planning officer please to
indicate now i'll give you a couple of
seconds if you want to do that
and failing that we'll move into a
debate
i'm seeing no action so let's move into
a debate who would like to kick us off
councilman mills is typing so i shall
beat him to it and say counselor mills
come on then
should i go for it mr chairman please do
oh sorry
um wow um
when we all visit this site um i i have
to say
i i was a little bit concerned um
with the access to this site um it does
seem to be
a rather small cul-de-sac um
and if you do have an extra it will be
23
three houses on the back of the one on
the front and that we
it could be an extra 46 movements of
cars going through that middle
as it is a cul-de-sac at the moment
i quite like the idea of um
the the other entrance it was proposed
by uh was it mr
uh councillor simon carter um
i've probably got i mean i don't know
how many more houses wealth can take i
don't know
but um i'm just a little bit concerned
about mr chairman i'll wait to
what everybody else has to say but at
the moment i'm
i'm i'm feeling a bit uncomfortable
anyway i'll uh i'll see what everybody
assessments jim thank you
understood thank you very much councilor
mills i would just say that what you've
alluded to in an alternative entrance we
do
have to consider the application that is
in front of us
uh rather than alternatives i understand
i quite understand that mr chairman
thank you
thank you okay um counselor adam has
indicated to speak cancer
thank you chairman um there are a few
things that concern me about this
application i think
the principle of it and the housing mix
generally does look fine and i think
that there's clearly a lot of work
that's gone in to make that the case and
i think the the points that were made by
the parish councillor
that his you know feels bad that he had
to object
sort of you know grounded with me
i think it's it should be the case that
road safety
should not be fundamentally equated with
not with detriment to the to the
community i think there can be a safe
road layout which still causes detriment
to the neighbors
i how much weight that carries through
our policies i think is
is somewhat beyond me at the moment
the thing that really gets me more than
anything um because it's something i see
in this application as with many others
is that the actual number of
uh houses that are being proposed for
welford within the core strategy
period is going to be far in excess of
the recommended
number now i do completely accept that
is a recommendation not an upper limit
but at the moment by the from what i can
tell
at this point without this we're at 150
odds time percent of the recommended
amount
and this would push it to about 180
what really concerns me about that isn't
just the
initial impact that might happen to the
community from having
this increase in housing with potential
of not having adequate infrastructure
but also the fact that when we come to
renew our core strategy
we're going to be looking for sites to
put new houses
and these sites sites that have
otherwise
been shown to be perfectly good for
housing mix
and development uh notwithstanding the
the issues that have been raised
um aren't going to be available and i
think that's a real
issue which we really should make sure
is does carry material weight so that we
don't
over develop um local service villages
as with any other
type of settlement i think that holds
much more weight than gets allowed for
um i know that i've spoken on previous
applications but that has carried enough
weight
um the fact that it's under the proposed
uh sap arrangement is tier seven which
means it is already
um subject to excessive uh development
uh demonstrates that we will we as a
council are appreciating that
and so with that in life i'd say under
cs
16 we could um refuse this
and have it uh covered by our own
policies to make sure that that is
um within planning ground so i would uh
make the proposal that we do refuse
under cs 16. okay
thank you cancer adam council candle
thank you chairman um i've got to
disagree i'm afraid with
counselor adam i i'm looking through uh
over and over again i'm seeing no
objections no objections no objections
from everywhere
except obviously from the parish council
and and people of the village look
i get i get it it's welford's had a lot
of building
i really i do sympathize with them but
i'm struggling to find
what i think of sound planning grounds
not to go
with this application and in addition to
that
although there may be better site access
as you correctly said earlier
we've got to go with the application
before us and i can't
i can't find a reason not to support the
officer on this occasion i think she's
done a very good job
in putting together a report on this um
i understand council adam's put together
put a proposal
across i think i would make a counter
proposal but to come back to that later
uh nobody feel free to make it now i
would propose that we grant subject to
the one
section 106. okay lovely thank you very
much councillor
um before i give my two pennies worth i
shall call in those that have indicated
to speak so counselor hench your
seraphim first
thank you chair um i have a reservation
of the access with lack of consideration
for the residents of that small class
i also agree with councillor adam
welford at the moment does not need
extra housing
um so
that's that's what i can say i can't say
anymore to what council adam has said
and i would support refuse
when you say support refuse are you
supporting or is that second thing
i'm second in council adam's refusal
okay thank you that's clear
okay um councillor fleming next please
okay thank you chairman um i know we're
judging what's in front of us tonight
but we are so close to a very acceptable
solution
um that whilst i want to
say that i would uh i would refuse to i
would
support reviews tonight is because of
the people who live at number four and
five
barton fields um i think you know
they've had 40 years of having five
houses
down there then all of a sudden they're
going to have 29
and i think the parish council put it
very well when they said
we're very close to a solution here it
just needs a little bit more thought
and i think with that a little bit more
thought they could they could get it
sorted
but i would have to say on the plan in
front of us with
access via number five barton fields
i would have to say i wouldn't support
the the officer's recommendation
thank you lovely thank you
um i will put my tip in his worth in now
as as no one else has indicated to speak
um before i'm just going to dive in
straight in and second councillor
kendall's um
uh proposal to grant uh and the reason
for that is very much in the same
vein as he has put that we have no
statutory consultees
coming back with an objection the two
reasons i'm hearing from
cancer adam and cancer and seraphin are
uh on
and indeed counselor fleming are on the
um highways grounds we have
no objection from highways it's very
difficult to go against and no objection
from highways
and then about numbers and as councilor
adam has pointed out
the limit that was put on is in fact it
is not an upper limit
um it is a guide number um a lot of
what council adam has said um referred
to policy change
rather than our actual policy is now the
planning committee is not the
opportunity to make a policy change
counselors we're here to make decisions
on the policies
as they are in place in our core
strategy and indeed through
the neighborhood development plans um so
i cannot support a refusal on that basis
given we have
no objection from all statutory
consultees um i
certainly cannot come up with any other
planning reason why we should go against
that
and so to say i'm going to be supporting
um
and seconding council kendall's proposal
uh i can see council henry serafin and
casa adam have asked if they could come
back and speak i'm gonna
uh hence your seraphim council and sarah
and you were first i shall ask you first
please
yes thank you chair um i have noted
there
is 138 letters of objection
which hasn't been raised before
surely that counts for something
uh okay um i mean we we do get a huge
number of objections um
yes i mean i could refer you to the
previous application
application where we had over 700 we
still moved to grant
um so whilst they all objections uh and
letters filed by the public
are considered throughout the planning
process um
the number in themselves does not
dictate the uh and it's not a planning
reason to refuse
yeah i think excuse me i think
that it does need to be looked at again
it could come up with better proposals
on this development
understood and i'm going to call cancer
adam in now that's right
thank you chairman um just wanted for
absolute clarity on
the point i was making um i believe it
is within our current policy
um to try and protect the five-year land
supply
um and that that has to um apply to
with a view to future strategies as well
without a change of policy
um i think um
that is something that we can justify uh
refusing on under cs16
um as we have had other cases in the
past where that has
been the basis for refusal and there's
precedent there
um i don't think this is a policy matter
i think like i said
the the case officers clearly done a lot
of work and i'm i'm
quite happy with that otherwise but that
it's the numbers that
that is the issue for me and i think we
do have a solid basis for
for that under our current um policies
okay understood um i i'm gonna have to
defer to our planning manager for
for their wisdom on this um so tracy if
you'd like to come in now
and and some eyes for us that'd be very
helpful
thank you chairman um yes obviously
we've listened to the debate and
obviously the speakers as well we do
understand the strength of feeling with
the application
just to remind members and you can see
from the uh the reference number for the
application it's been on the books for
some considerable time
and that reflects the fact that it's
been subject to considerable negotiation
throughout that time period
uh specifically uh with highways and
thank you to county highways john for uh
for joining us this evening
um in terms of the the principle of the
development it remains within the
the built up area boundary and the
numbers that the core strategy
identifies for welford as has been
mentioned is is not an upper limit
and it's therefore appropriate for us to
consider both the principle of the
residential development of the site
and uh the scale of development um as
part of our consideration of the
acceptability of the proposal
we've gone through that in some depth in
the report and we've analyzed why we
feel that this is small scale
and is therefore acceptable in principle
within the built-up area boundary
and that's a point that the the agent
made in her presentation as well
we do understand what members and the
public feel might be
a more satisfactory um from their
perspective
alternative access arrangement
nevertheless
the chairman and others are quite right
that we have to determine the
application on the basis of the access
provision in front of us
that has been found to be acceptable by
our
county colleagues we do thank the
the applicants and the objectives for
going through the further transport
submissions which have been made during
the life of the application it has
allowed some additional scrutiny
um but we do feel that we do not have a
highway safety reason for refusal given
that county support the proposal
officers have weighed all these issues
in the balance and we do feel that the
benefits of the scheme
um outweigh um uh any dis benefits
and we point out as the uh the case
officer mentioned in her summary that we
do have quite a substantial package of
both section 106
contributions and there would also be
quite a substantial sill payment to
reflect the infrastructure needs
of the development putting all that
together officers do feel that the
balance
of the recommendation does favor
supporting the application
but clearly with those conditions and
that legal agreement
that's a terrific summation thank you um
i i specifically would like some
guidance i think this would be helpful
for the entire committee to be honest
there's a specific like some guidance on
the reason for refusal has been put by
councillor adam
uh which i i understand now to be
isolated to the numbers council adam if
you give me a nod is that correct
or if you could give yourself full
wording for it that's a nod from cancer
adam so it's about the numbers
could you give us um uh
an understanding of uh the strength of
that reason for refusal
um and if we have any evidence to
suggest that it
it may not be strong enough to be upheld
at appeal that's what i'm looking for
please
thank you chairman well obviously the uh
we have
a number of examples which have been
given us in the the agent's presentation
as to where call descent developments of
uh similar and varied sizes have been
found to be acceptable
um i can only reiterate that there is no
upper limit
um within the um the numbers the core
strategy envisages for
um for welford um and obviously with the
site being
within the build superior boundary as
identified in the ndp
then again the principle of development
we feel to be acceptable
um we don't feel as officers that we
have a sufficient case to
uh support a reason for refusal based
on cs16 which uh councillor adam was
uh was referring to um clearly
if a refusal along those lines was to be
made
then um it would be up to the planning
inspector to determine those issues but
officers are quite clear that we feel
that the development should be supported
given that it's clearly located within
the built-up area boundary
and we've analyzed clearly within the
report what we feel to be the issues
that makes it qualifiers
as a small scale development as as
policy supports
okay lovely thank you um okay
uh so well we have on the table uh
a a proposal and it has been seconded
to refuse uh on cs16 grounds
that's the first one that was made so we
must hear that first cancel adam given
you made that could you just please
uh clarify uh the wording of or exactly
um
what you want the wording to be for your
reason for refusal before we move to a
vote
sure um
um
given the uh current
housing numbers approved within welford
um under the current core strategy being
significantly in excess of the
recommended
limit
being further increased by the proposed
development under cs16
i believe that
this um provides
material um consideration in the
planning balance
to refuse
okay um i'm going to assume councillor
henshaw serafin is happy with that as he
was the seconder
uh yes chair happy okay thank you
um councillor crump did you want to
speak at this point you've indicated you
wanted to speak
just just very briefly um i know time's
running on
um i did listen to councillor carter and
i was very impressed with what he had to
say
and i'm sure i heard it he wasn't
particularly concerned
about the numbers i think he actually
said with a little bit of work
regarding the highways and potentially
the sewers
the scheme would have been perfectly
acceptable so therefore
he was giving tacit approval to the
numbers he didn't mention the numbers so
i just thought that's a relevant point i
might have misheard him to apologize if
i do but
i just thought i'd raise that point
thank you
okay thank you councillor crump that was
my interpretation as well
nevertheless we do have a proposal that
has been seconded uh for refusal for the
reason given
um we will move to a vote now i will go
first councillor richards
against councillor fleming
against councillor dixon
i must have stain uh my wife i dropped
out during mr chapman's early remarks
and i came back in during
liz nicholson's closing remarks i shall
be abstaining on any proposal on this
case
thank you councillor dixon councillor
hunter seraphin
for and councillor mills
uh for refusal for this application
chair that's three four four against in
one abstention
okay so uh that proposal therefore fails
we do have a second proposal which was
put by councillor kendall
and supported by myself secondly by
myself um that is to grant
uh in line with the officer's
recommendation and details within the
update sheet we will move again straight
to a vote i will start councillor
richards
four councillor fleming
cancer fleming abstain
counselor kendall councillor kendall
four
councillor adam
clarke adam against councillor cramp
catch the grump for councillor dixon i'm
gonna put you as staying
i think is it internet's dropped out
again council hunter seraphin
against and councillor mills
council mills against chair that's
two four three against and two
abstentions
no that's right
a different way wrong there is three
four
three against and two abstentions
which leaves the casting vote to myself
is that right
okay yes fabulous given i seconded
uh grant and i can see no reason for
refusal
um uh of the application i will maintain
that
and therefore committee will resolve to
grant planning application
uh 1903 113 ful
uh in welfare that's kellstein in
welford on haven
okay now let's move on to
our next item
so this application uh application
reference twenty zero two
zero one four fuel is item six uh
members will be aware that item has been
withdrawn so we will move
straight past that one and we will move
to uh the application number
seven which is uh twenty zero one five
four nine full
uh tai nee and uh harbory
our presenting officer is paul thompson
paul if you are ready to go
please do thank you chair
and good evening councillors ladies and
gentlemen um
i hope you can all see and hear me
only briefly because we'll go straight
to
this is that is that coming through for
everyone
it is yes great okay this is
uh a householder application in the in
the north
east of harboury um it backs on to
the site of special scientific interest
and railway
and is also adjacent to the conservation
areas indicated on this plan by the
the purple boundary um
the existing property is a two-story
semi-detached structure with
a detached garage and a projecting
element at the rear
the proposal is a two-story side
extension
um the subservient ridgeline
set slightly back from the front
elevation and a single story
projecting element at the rear with a
flat roof
this is the floor plan and
here is what it looks like at the moment
as property on the right
with the cream walls there's a
fairly sizable gap to the right
as you stand as you face it on the road
and uh that is pretty much all all there
is to say that the recommendation
is to grant planning permission subject
conditions sure
marvelous thank you very much um we will
move very quickly to our
first speaker uh who is
counselor samantha allen from harboury
parish council
counselor alan are you there you may
need to press start and six to unmute
yourself
yes i am here hello good evening thank
you for your patience with us
um we will dive straight in so you have
three minutes we'll give you a 30 second
warning before that time is up
and if you could stay on the line for
any questions afterwards uh that would
be greatly appreciated
whenever you're ready please feel free
to begin okay thank you for the
opportunity to address you regarding
this application
um tiny is one of a semi-detached pair
of modest size victorian workers
cottages
adjacent to the conservation area in
hungary this application is for a large
incongruous enlargement of the dwelling
in question
which significantly increases the
footprint disproportionately
the increase is 132 of the current floor
area
which would have a dominant and
detrimental effect to the next door twin
cottage
and in turn the street scene harvard
parish council rarely comment on
extension plans in the parish
but in this case we considered the
proposed unbelief unbalanced
modifications to the building
do not reflect or complement the local
character and this application therefore
disregards h05 of our neighborhood
development plan
as it does not constitute good design
the overbearing insensitive design does
not comply with local plan policies cs5
for landscape and impact cs9 design and
distinctiveness
or cs20 b which is alterations and
modifications
because it lacks appropriate scale
terrace was
originally included in the initial
proposal which the case officer confirms
would result in unacceptable overlooking
of the neighbor to the east
although the report to the committee
indicates this has been removed from the
scheme
this is not the case the redacted plans
show the roof line of the test has been
arranged from the plan
but it is clear that the 1.1 metre solid
glass ballast rate remains and would
likely be installed
whilst the coast officer has recommended
that granting the application based
on the flat roof not to be used as an
external sitting out terrace area
approving the current application set of
clans with a balustrude in place
and two full height doorways to the area
make this recommendation
undeliverable with an unenforceable
future situation
i would confirm that the inclusion of
the terrorists would directly contravene
cs 9b
of the local plan which protects
neighbouring buildings from a loss of
privacy
for these reasons outlined we would
respectfully ask you to reconsider this
application along with our concerns
and refuse this application in its
current form thank you very much
council ryan thank you very much for
that members do you have any questions
for our counselor
i'm seeing lots of shaking heads and
nothing in our meeting chat so council
ryan thank you very much for your
contribution this evening
if you want to continue watching on the
online portal that would be the best way
to do it but thank you very much thank
you
okay moving to our next speaker who is
uh mrs susan
turner mrs turner are you there you may
need to press start and 6 to unmute
yourself
hopefully we will be able to hear you in
a second
mrs turner i'm not sure if you can hear
us um you will need to press start
six on your keypad in order to unmute
yourself
just to reiterate mr turner star and six
on the keypad
i do so love modern technology
mrs tan are you able to hear us
could i ask our committee services guys
if they could see if they can bring
turner in
please gemma mrs turner is him but she's
muted and we we
can't unmute her oh i've just seen a
number unmute mrs turner are you there
we can't hear you at the moment i can
see a number that has been unmuted i'm
assuming it's you
we're unable to hear you at the moment
is there potentially another mute button
on your phone that may have prevented us
from hearing your microphone
can someone give her a call
[Music]
yeah um i'm going to ask our solicitor
for his guidance here given that we have
mr turner register to speak but she's
unable to um uh be heard at the moment
uh how do we proceed as a committee do
we need to continue through
or do we can we adjourn do we must must
we adjourn in order to
hear mr tennessee why don't we have a
short adjournment to see if we can get a
hold of her
i think that sounds like a good idea
we'll take two minutes
um and see if we can get a hold of mrs
turner if we
can we will continue uh shortly if we
can't we will i believe we'll have to
move straight through to
clarification and then on to
the debate but two minutes while we see
if we can bring it back in
let's recent comments
german i believe mrs turner may be in
the room now if you just ask her to
unmute herself
lovely thank you very much mr turner if
you're there if you could press start
and six to unmute
um i haven't told that i am on youtube
we've got you we can hear you
excellent lovely thank you the relief
that gives me
oh i'm glad you're here uh so
members are we i just want to check
members are still back um and in front
of their screens
uh before we progress it looks like we
all
are we are fabulous
okay ms senna you have three minutes
we'll give you a 30 second warning
when you finish um if you could stay on
the line for questions
and that would be perfect whenever
you're ready please please do feel free
to start
thank you mr chairman kynai and the
adjoining property
which end are fine examples of
traditional victorian cottages
and the proposed plan will result in the
properties looking unbalanced from the
street view
and completely destroy the character of
the original concept
although the resubmitted plans show a
slight reduction in floor area
the proposed extension is still out of
scale and context with the existing
building
this development would also create yet
another large property within the
village
which is already lacking in the
availability of small to medium-sized
houses
the dramatic increase in size of the
floor plan and hence roof area
will result in the doubling of the
runoff from stormwater
which will add considerably to the
groundwater draining through the
proposed soak aways
possibly affecting the railway cutting
recent developments along this part of
hall lane have resulted in noise
destruction parking problems and
extensive damage to the pound village
green opposite
which is an important heritage area in
harbory
when considering this application
attention should be given to the issue
of parking
of contractors and delivery vehicles
we're already experiencing problems
relating to contractors working at china
since it was purchased
parking their vehicles on the narrow
pavement outside our property
and causing an obstruction due to the
proximity of the neighbouring properties
and the scale of proposed development if
this application is successful
would it be possible for the hours of
construction to be limited
to 8 a.m to 6 p.m monday to friday
8 00 to 1 pm saturday and no working on
sundays or bank holidays
thank you mr chairman
uh thank you very much mr santa members
do you have any questions
please i am seeing lots of shaking heads
and there are no questions um thank you
again son of your contribution this
evening
um uh we will be moving into uh officer
uh clarification in just a moment um so
feel free to continue watching on the
online portal but thank you again
for your contribution thank you
members do we have any points of
clarification for our
i should say our ward member is not
registered to speak and we have no other
registered
speakers do we have any points of
clarification for our officer
lots of shaken heads again
shall we move into debate who would like
to start on the debate
ah now we have a couple of questions uh
counselor dixon you have a question
thank you chairman hopefully you
couldn't hear me um i must admit i did
drop out again but
not on this particular application uh
we've just had a request from mrs turner
for a
uh a working time uh
condition uh would the officer like to
uh to speak to that please
uh yeah that's that's not not something
we'd normally apply to
to householder and development
counsellor but it is an option available
to you should you wish to
exercise it thank you i think i would be
in favor of it
councilor mills
question to the officer uh to paul yes
yes um
have you got a um a plan showing the the
rear of the house um because there's a
concern from the
resident next door that it would
overshadow them or
be intrusive in some way
sorry council but by by plan do you do
you mean a photo or
yeah photo yes have you got a photo
there um bear with me just a second
yeah if i can bring up the
presentation that that that is the rear
of the house it should be on your
screens now
is that okay for you council mills yeah
okay thank you thank you very much
thank you marvellous let's move into
debate shall we
uh who would like to start us off
councillor mills
um i have to say um
i don't like the look of this it seems
to
you know to me it doesn't fit in with
the street scene
um it puts them out of balance with the
with it with a next door neighbor um
to me it doesn't look right mr chairman
at the moment but um
i don't like look at it i don't think it
fits in the street scene um but
i'll listen to what other people have
got to say at the moment thank you
okay thank you um any other members
wishing to take part in the debate
at this stage
no i will put my two pennies worth in
now
um i think the report has covered all
bases
really um and i am struggling to find
any planning reason to go
against uh what has been uh
presented as a as a recommendation for
grant so i will
um and that's having considered all the
updates and the speakers tonight so i
will propose that we do grant in line
with the officer's recommendation
i can see councillor kendall has
indicated a wish to speak councillor
kendall
yeah thank you chairman i understand
councilman's point i i don't think it
fits perfectly but
like you've said i can't see a valid
reason to go against
it i i don't think it looks wonderful
i think again if we were here to design
a better application we
we could maybe do that but i don't think
that's for this particular committee so
um i will second your proposal to grant
lovely thank you very much um members
have had
ample opportunity to indicate if they
want to speak uh councillor dixon has
just come in to councillor dixon
i would support those to that proposal
and the seconding but i would like to
see
that condition included to ensure that
work does not
occur on sundays or bank holidays or
saturday afternoons
i'm going to seek legal guidance on that
as to whether that is an appropriate
um condition to place on ross could you
confirm or otherwise
um the condition needs to be reasonable
um
i'd be interested in in the planning
manager's views as to whether
preventing construction on a sunday bank
holiday and saturday afternoons is
reasonable
um given in particular the recent
um sort of loosening of the rules around
construction
times that have been introduced by the
government
as part of sort of measures to get
get building again after covered so i've
just i'd be interested in the um
planning manager's views on the
reasonableness of that condition
i'll try to help if i can chairman
members um yes thanks
rossi you're quite correct that uh
recently um
local authorities have been encouraged
to be more flexible in terms of starting
and finishing times
in relation to construction sites our
general practice is to control
operating and construction hours
particularly on larger sites by
definition
they have a much longer duration of
construction
it's not been our practice to restrict
opening hours on householder extensions
i think that probably reflects the fact
that broadly they tend to be of a
shorter duration overall
and it might be that potentially a
proportion uh you know for example might
be self build in which case the added
flexibility to
um uh to applicants to uh to construct
uh up there at a time that's convenient
to them is
is perhaps important as well um
so our recommendation would be is that
we don't tend to put those
uh conditions and we wouldn't consider
it uh reasonable for a household or
extension to put those sort of
restrictions on
but paul is quite correct that if you
are entitled to uh to take a different
view if you
feel so and the applicant would be
entitled to appeal that condition if
if they felt we've been unreasonable in
adding it
lovely thank you councillor kendall
thank you sherman if i was the applicant
i would appeal it i think it's an
unreasonable uh restraint to put on the
um
on a on a small on an extension to
someone's house i think it's very
unusual to do that that's
always reserved for much much bigger
applications i
wouldn't support that uh i agree
entirely
um uh had it been for a series of houses
or
you know a plot of a larger plot
perhaps but uh on something uh as
you know something that's a two-story
side extension i think is is
um over the top and unnecessary let's
move to a vote
uh the proposal is to grant in line with
our office's recommendation i will go
first council richards
four thank you councillor fleming
council fleming for that's kendall
councillor kendall four councillor crump
christopher councillor dixon i hear what
members say
four council hunter seraphin
council entrance seraphine four and
councillor mills
councillor mills against
chair that's six four and one again one
against
lovely thank you very much so committee
therefore resolves to grant application
twenty zero one five four nine
f u l uh tiny in harbory
fabulous we'll move to our next um uh
our next application now i
i admitted of saying earlier that we did
have a slight juggling of our agenda
um in that uh the listed item under item
eight
um has been moved to our final item and
item nine has been moved forward one so
we are now going to be hearing
application reference 1903
574 ful that's luna's farm
um our presenting officer is charlotte
dix charlotte
over to you thank you chairman
just to check can you um can you see the
um
screen thank you thank you very much
the first slide shows the site indicated
by the
black dot the site is within the open
countryside approximately three quarters
of a kilometer from barchester village
and ships in london can also be seen to
the west of the site
the cotswolds aonb is approximately one
kilometer to the east
and the special landscape area is
approximately one kilometers to the
south
of the site this plan
shows the extent of the site indicated
by the red line
access is provided from the wilmington
road to the west
over here barcheston is located over
here
with the nearest residential property
borough hill farm
to the north of the site on the b4835
public right away ss 69 runs to the
south west of the site
shown by the dotted green line
so this is a full application this slide
shows the proposed site plan with the
entirety of the site
shown in the top corner for context this
plan shows the proposed location of the
three poultry sheds and the gate house
running east to west
with the existing building shown in
yellow over here
the attenuation basin would be to the
south of the existing building
this slide shows the proposed elevations
demonstrating the proposed 2.9 metre
high eaves and
6.2 metres to the ridge the six
feed bins are also visible at the top of
the slide you can see the proposed south
elevation
so this would be as viewed from the
public right away
over 300 meters away the north elevation
would be as
viewed from the b4035 the
rest would be as viewed from the
willington road
and the east as viewed from midlands
slurry site
this photo shows the access to the site
from the west
of willington road the open fields are
visible either side of the track along
with the existing vegetation
you can see that the ground level rises
away from the access
and the buildings will be beyond the
ridge that's visible
this photo is taken from the access
track within the site and adjacent to
the existing building
facing south towards the public right
away as shown by the arrow
the existing building is visible on the
left hand side this
is the subject this was the subject of
the agricultural notification
application in 2015
again you can see the ground level
rising up to the north
this photo is taken from the access
track
facing north towards borough hill farm
an agricultural building
associated with this farm is visible in
the background
the existing vegetation along the b4a35
can also be seen here
this motor is taken from within the site
facing
east towards the middle and slurry site
again as indicated by the arrow
braille's hill is also visible in the
background
this is a panorama shot from the eastern
boundary facing west towards wellington
road
the existing field boundary and
vegetation which is to be enhanced
with a woodland buffer can partly be
seen
this is taken from the side of the
existing building facing towards the
eastern boundary
the attenuation basin would be cited in
this location
this panorama is taken from the
willington raid facing towards the site
the buildings would be located beyond
the ridge
this is a photo taken from a field
access gap within the vegetation
along the field boundary with the b4a35
facing south the existing building on
the site can be visible
in the background
just to confirm there are no updates
officer recommendation
is to approve subject the conditions and
notes on pages 83-84
thank you very much
thank you very much for that um members
we will move straight to our speakers we
have no parish council registered to
speak tonight but we do have a resident
uh mr tom murray mr murray are you there
can you hear me
you may need to press star and six to
unmute yourself
hi there yeah i can hear you chair we
can indeed fabulous
um you have three minutes we'll give you
a 30 second warning and if you could
stay on the line afterwards for any
questions that would be great
whenever you're ready please begin
thanks chad thanks everyone um
this development is likely to have a
significant and continual impact on our
surroundings and our lives
we have four concerns the first
increased traffic
this development will generate over 170
articulated lorry
trips in and out of the site each flock
cycle
these vehicles are currently an
incredibly rare occurrence on our lanes
this is likely to have serious safety
implications particularly on the
crossroads to the north
drivers coming from the east only see
this crossroads from about 50 meters
away
giving them little time to react the
application refers to crash statistics
but these seem a little relevant given
we've never had so many articulated
lorries pulling out into the road
there have been two accidents there in
the last few weeks alone and two
fatalities in recent years
displays and current speed limit will
not mitigate this danger
there is a safety issue for the many
cyclists and walkers who use these lanes
which has increased significantly since
covid
the increased traffic will have a noise
impact day and night
the recent delivery of supplies to the
site could be heard through the night
this increased heavy vehicle traffic
will also have to go over the ancient
and narrow ships and bridge
which is already congested and has a
busy and completely unprotected footpath
on its northern edge
our second concern is visual impact the
impact on this beautiful landscape so
close to an aomb
and sla is still classed as moderate
even after the proposed mitigants
the height of the feed bins will be much
greater than anything else around
the trees will take 15 years to reach
fruition and still be lower than the
feed bins
they will do litter in the little in the
winter there are concerns that the
woodland to the west will not obscure
the site from that direction
there will be light pollution at night
from the security lights
our third concern is environmental
impact the odor in particular from the
spreading of waste on the site will be
there all year round
there seems to be a heightened risk of
flooding in pollution into the rivers
tower which already floods
and we've all read the recent reports of
the pollution the river y from intensive
poultry developments
the nature of this development also
seems at odds with the council's
ambitions to reduce the district's
carbon footprint
our fourth and final concern is the
enforceability of the site's obligations
if it is approved
we strongly object to this proposal if
it is to go ahead we suggest also adding
these conditions
house of operation confined to daytime
to limit noise
lights as low as as low level as
practically possible
and planting of mature trees further up
the hill to the west
dangers to walkers and cyclists seem
difficult if not impossible to prevent
shipstand is getting ever closer to our
villages of blackstone and wellington to
our west
to have the prospect of an industrial
development
with three structures each as long as a
football pitch was so close to our east
is a huge concern which we feel will
have a permanent impact on this very
special
and peaceful place thank you
thank you very much mr murray um just in
time members do we have any questions
for our speaker
please indicate in the chat if you do
i'm seeing a lot of shaking heads so i'm
going to assume that's a no
mr murray thank you uh very much for
your contribution this evening uh there
are no questions so
um you're free to go please do continue
to watch on the online portal
um but for now if you want to hang out
the phone that's great and thank you
again for your contribution
thanks everyone bye thank you
so our next speakers um our applicants
and their agents so i have
james wilding and john i'm i think this
is pronounced calper but please correct
me if i'm wrong
um if you could please press star and
six
on your keypads hopefully we'll be able
to hear you
star on six
hello chairman can you hear me i can who
am i speaking to
uh this is james wilding and it's only
me that will be speaking not the
applicant
okay lovely that's no problem at all um
uh mr wilding you have three minutes
we'll give you a 30 second
warning please stay on the line for
questions afterwards whenever you're
ready feel free to start
thank you chair thank you uh committee
members uh this application
follows pre-application consultation
with the council in january 2018
and follow the withdrawal of application
1900 561
ful to resolve outstanding matters
relating to highways drainage and
landscape matters
through substantive and proactive
working with the planning department the
applicant has sought to put forward a
comprehensive
and well thought out scheme which
hopefully can now receive full council
sport
in terms of the principle of development
as stated back in 2018 and reaffirmed by
the case officer here
there is a clear agricultural need for
the development and the proposal meets
the objective of core strategy policy
as10 due to the nature and scale of the
activity although not
large as some broiler units recently
approved the schema schedule won eia
development and an environmental permit
is also needed
from the environment agency to operate
the site the environmental statement and
permit submission
extensively detailed the potential
environmental effects on
amenity odor ammonia noise dust and
waste drainage pest control flooding and
the impact on
statistically and non-statutory
designated habitats
the environment agency are content that
the planned unit can operate without
harm to the environment
or human health and granted a permit on
the 22nd of
january 2019. aside from the
environmental effects which have been
accepted by statutory consultees
the council has also given considerable
thoughts of potential highway and
landscape implications
and following the provision of
additional information officers are
content that the proposal would be
acceptable
in terms of its impact on highways in
accordance with the requirements of
policy cs26
of the core strategy and paragraphs 108
and 109 of the
in a landscape terms the proposal would
comply with policies cs5
cs9 cs11 cs12 and as10 of the core
strategy
the cotswold amb management plan and
paragraph 172 of the mppf the case
office has concluded overall that the
current application
conforms to the development plan and
associated guidance
under the aims and requirements of the
mppf and that there are no material
considerations
that warrant an alternative approach on
this basis the officer
recommends approval of the scheme
subject to conditions
paragraph 38 of the mppf states that
local planning authorities
should approach decisions on proposed
development in a positive and creative
way
decision makers at every level should
seek to approve applications for
sustainable development
where possible this application is
considered to be sustainable and
conforms to the development plan and
requirements of the mppf
on this basis we respectfully request
committee members
to support this application thank you
very much
mr wilding thank you very much members
could you indicate in the chat if you
have
any questions for our agent of the
outcomes agent
councilmills
thanks ms jim oh good evening um
i wonder if you could tell me um i take
it the um
it will be live chicks that will be
brought into uh
the sheds for wonderful better word um
can you tell me what the uh
would it be when would be the
the the best time well how old would the
chickens be before you know when they
would leave the shed for
to go out for consumption and also
how many movements would there be i said
traffic movements uh
to um to make this viable this uh
before this year and also how many can
you
tell me how many chickens will be
involved in this you know
on how many chickens per shed as well i
would like to know
okay um to hopefully answer all of those
questions
um it's uh yes you you are correct that
the birds would come in as day old
chicks
um they would be reared on a 40-day
growing cycle
which is a standard growing cycle um
there would be a five to seven day
cleaning program after that
and then a new crop would arrive shortly
after
so that would be looking at round about
seven crops
per annum in terms of
the number of traffic
movements we
have uh set out within both transport
statement and the environmental impact
assessment there's 136 two-way movements
um to um per
crop um so of those about
um 86 of those are two-way movements
which are hgb related
um so uh that compares to
um you know the traffic data along the
4035 for example
which was 3 300 in a on a day
um and uh you know some
uh uh 560 along the unknown lane so
the traffic numbers are very very small
less than one percent
of the overall traffic generation i'm
sorry what
what what other points outstanding
i think that's about it but i'd like to
ask
would this be um continue continuing
at um at night time as well with
nighttime movements
no so the the uh the lights are
uh there's no lights on during the night
um unless for whatever reason there was
an emergency on the site
and and lighting had to be switched on
so otherwise it's a dark site during the
night
in terms of deliveries um there may be
on occasion the requirements to
deliver or remove birds during the night
um
but otherwise all other other traffic
movements will be during working hours
thank you
okay i've seen no further questions from
members you've got a quick couple of
seconds
if anyone wants to jump in now
i'm not seeing any movement so um uh
thank you very much mrs welding for your
contribution this evening
feel free to continue to watch on our
online portal otherwise
now for me to thank you again um and if
you would hang up the phone so we can
continue the meeting that would be great
thank you very much pleasure thanks very
much thanks
castro dahl is our ward member uh
councillor donald are you there and
ready to speak
uh i am indeed chair yes marvellous you
know the drill
five minutes 30 second warning stay
online for questions whenever you're
ready
please commence thank you very much good
evening committee
um i fully support any positive addition
to the rural economy within my ward
i believe that we have to as a rural
district support our forward planning
professionally minded
intergenerational farming businesses i
had the pleasure of visiting the
applicant's poultry farm in krimskit
and it is a clean well-run unit with
strict biosecurity and on that
particular day
very little odor it is of note that the
applicant has positively front loaded
with engaging with the parish
meeting and the ward member however
it is important to frame the concerns
raised by residents as we consider a
large poultry farm application for 155
broilers
near a small tranquil rural hamlet
this hamlet will receive no benefit
whatsoever from this development
with no section 106 or no sale money
attached
instead the residents of a little
forgotten hamlet which doesn't enjoy the
best internet or modern facilities
are being asked to replace tranquility
with extra traffic
volume traffic noise increased odor
pollution and a visual impact upon the
outlook
so close to the anob that they and their
families have enjoyed for generations
given the visual impact does it meet cs5
and cs9
15 years is a long time to wait for a
visual impact to be mitigated
concerns have quite rightly been raised
about the suitability and safety of
transport routes popular with walkers
and cyclists especially postcovid
and consistently people have raised
concern around the suitability
of the b4035 and an increase we've just
heard an extra
86 hgv traffic movements to pass over
the narrow shipston bridge which is
already congested and of concern
the cpre are campaigning for a change in
planning policy to recognize that
intensive livestock units are
industrial development with impacts as
harmful as other large industries
and that they should be located on
brownfield land with good transport
connections away from people's homes
and on sites where landscape would not
be harmed basically not in the open
countryside now barchester residents
have raised concerns around water
pollution
and if we look to hereford as previously
mentioned the growth in the intensive
poultry industry has coincided with a
rise in phosphate levels in the river y
and the river lug
and poultry litter contains more
phosphorus than any other farm manure as
well as arsenic and other residues
the applicant has suggested that there
is an economic benefit from this
application
or for clarification around this how
many people will be employed
and how will it increase tourism and
bring money into the surrounding areas
i assist as this development cannot be
seen surely as sustainable and i
question how it's supporting as-10
therefore when we are asking such a huge
amount from our neighbouring villages it
is only right and just that they have a
strong reassurance
through watertight conditions if you
choose to grant
on the applications such as traffic how
will this be monitored and at what time
of night will the hour of acceptance
acceptable ambient noise take place as
cited in the offices report
the color of the sheds this needs to be
specified agreed and enforced to ensure
they blend with the countryside
how is this application fitting with our
net zero by 2030 climate emergency
and given the negative impact noted upon
biodiversity in the report
whilst minimal how will this be
counter-balanced by the applicant
and the environmental permit was awarded
pre on declaration of a climate
emergency so it's worth noting that
how can the odor aspect be monitored by
sdc
as with people working from home all
this will impact upon their daily living
and working experience
and what strict flood prevention and
pollution prevention measures are in
place and how these being forced
monitored and policed
and how can you reassure my residents
that this is not the thin end of the
wedge and as the business grows
a few workers caravans won't appear and
then another property be required on the
site
after all this is is this
diversification
as the applicant stated in his statement
or simply expansion of an existing
successful business
with the lighting how will it be done in
a way to prevent significant impact and
what security measures will be in place
around animal rights and protest groups
so whilst i fully support the
applicant's drive and determination to
meet the customer demands
i must ask you as a committee to ensure
that in our drive to meet the nation's
need for healthy homegrown chicken
we do not forget our residents who will
be adversely impacted by this
application
thank you so donna thank you very much
members do we have any questions for our
ward member
please indicate in the chat if you do
counselor mills i believe has a question
councilor mills thank you good evening
pennian o'donnell good me counselor
mills
i actually did ask the question but um i
didn't follow it up with the
the agent do you know how many
birds per shed there will be has have
you been told
so i i might need to be corrected by the
office but i thought it was 155 000
broilers
yes it was that that's in total isn't it
i think it's in total yes yeah it's a
considerably large application
i had i had missed that that's great
thank you very much
i'm sorry to ask you that foul question
you haven't ruffled my furnace don't
worry
another portrait come on let's re-focus
on the meeting please
um okay are there any additional
questions for our ward member
no okay in that case counselor donald
thank you very much please continue to
watch from
your uh from from teams thank you very
much
let's move to offices clarification
points does anyone have a point of
clarification
for our offices
no okay uh in that case
um we have i have had on um
i just need to go into a private chat
very briefly with our legal officer and
with our planning manager they have a
point they need to raise with me so just
bear with will again
my okay members forgive me for that uh
very brief interlude um
everything has been cleared up so we are
free to move on so um
we have no uh questions for our officers
um so uh let's move into the debate
members please who would like to speak
first
councillor kendall far away thank you
chairman
um i think this is quite an easy one for
me uh
not every business development can bring
direct benefit to a community
as far as i can see this is a very it's
a very good application it will be
beneficial to the economy as in
the wider economy and for that reason
i'm happy to propose that we grant
this lovely thank you very much
councilman mills was second up councilor
mills
um thanks mr chairman yes um
i i have gosh i seem against everybody
tonight i have
a reservation on this one only because
we we had a very very similar
application in my ward battles marston
and um probably the same number shared
same number of birds
enormous amount of um traffic
was um involved um
i i think we've got to be careful what
we wish for here it's it's going to make
an
awful lot of difference to that to
bargerton and shipston
um again i'll wait to see what everybody
else has got to say but
um at the moment as you've heard before
i'm a bit uncomfortable about this thank
you
thank you councilman mills councillor
dixon thank you chairman
uh i think councillor kendall uh
proposed a grant on this one i'm very
happy to second
um essentially looking from the
presentation and the photographs of the
site from
practically every angle possible i
thought the visual impact would be
fairly
minimal and i think given the long list
of conditions that the
report includes on page 83 i think a lot
of the
ward members concerns would equally
address through those conditions
thank you thank you very much council
fleming
thank you sorry chairs muting was being
a bit difficult
um this is an agricultural business
i know it's been described as being
industrial but you know
uh it it's in in the countryside it's i
think it's far enough away that it's not
going to be detrimental
uh to the people who live there i've
lived next door to one of these things
in the past and uh it's not a
they don't impact horribly on people um
i'm sure with the conditions that are
listed as as tony just recently said
um i think they can overcome most of
those um
and i'd be happy to support this
thank you councillor fleming there are
no one else no one else has indicated
their wish to speak
um so uh i i will uh move to a
vote i'm an agreement with what has been
said by councillor dixon fleming and
indeed kendall so i will start
councillor richards four
mr fleming
oh you're meeting planning for
cancer kendall councillor kendall four
councillor cramp that's the crown for
councillor dixon councillor dixon for
councillor hunter sarafin and sorry
anxious seraphin abstain
okay and councillor mills uh against
chair that's five four one against one
abstention
no thank you olivia and that case uh
committee resolves to uh grant
application 1903
574 ful lunan's farm um
members we are very quickly approaching
our nine o'clock deadline
and i'm conscious that uh it is not half
an hour before
and we have one item left um the
constitution is very clear
that we must uh cease it uh after three
hours
um and any application taken after half
past eight to half an hour before that
three hour
time limit will be the last given we
have five minutes
and only on the basis and this is only
on uh for this application
so not setting a precedent uh there are
no speakers
um this has only been brought uh to to
the committee as a result of
uh or by virtue of the applicant being
related to a council employee i'm
willing to take a vote to see if we
continue
um let's do that uh councillor kendall
do you want to speak
i was just going to ask what the legal
position was uh my understanding is this
will be unconstitutional
given the changes made recently what's
your view or
legal view my view is it it would be
against the committee procedure rules
but um ultimately it's for the chairman
um
yeah it's for the chairman and members
of committee whether they want to hear
this
this last application um but yeah it
will be against the procedure ross would
it be
um would it be fair to say that we can
take a vote to go against procedure
rules on
on the basis that i put that this is a a
very much a one-off and purely because
we have
zero speakers and it's an accounting
employee is that a fair
summation the procedure rules i don't
think anymore allow you to take a vote
but ultimately as chairman
you've got wide discretion on how you
run the meeting
and you might take the view that in
these particular circumstances
um you're happy to carry on um
you need to look at the harm i agree
with you i don't think it's setting a
precedent
um but it's up to you and the members
i know it is frustrating that it would
be a quick
application but it is on the
constitution
okay i understand um uh please can
people stop interrupting while we're
speaking because we're wasting more time
the our legal officer has laid out the
position that it it would be against the
constitution
i'm willing to seek members guidance i'm
willing to go ahead with it but i'm also
willing to seek members guidance
could you show your hand if you're
willing to take this now just so that
it's done because it's going to be quick
i've got two thumbs up i've got three
thumbs up i've got one no
four thumbs up five thumbs up council
candle i'm sorry we are we
will we'll very quickly hear this so um
application twenty zero zero five nine
seven
full um izzy howell is our presenting
officer is he over to you
hello um oh
can you see everything okay oh yeah
yeah okay so
one five seven evisceration road uh lies
within the adopted built up area
boundary of stratfor nathan
and can be identified with the black
dots
the application dwelling is a detached
dwelling set back from the mainly vision
road outlined by the red line in the
center of this plan
this is a full planning application for
a single story side extension
single story rear extension a new porch
and a garage to the front of the
dwelling
it follows an existing extant permission
1801
380 full with the main differences being
the inclusion of a single story side
extension
a slightly larger first floor rear
extension and a mended design to the
front of the property
this is the existing elevations of the
dwelling it's a detached four bedroom
dwelling with parking to the front
here we can see the proposed elevations
of the development which include
single and two-story rear extension a
single-story side extension a new porch
and a garage
the proposed floor plans have
alterations but the dwelling remains as
a four-bedroom house
the initial proposal included a
two-story side extension
but amendments have since been received
to overcome the neighbor issues
this photo is taken facing in a
northwestern direction looking towards
the site from the street scene
this image is taken from the garden of
the application property
located where the single story side
extension is proposed
this photo shows the existing rear
garden looking towards number 158
evisceration road slightly further back
into the garden
and this photo shows the existing garden
looking towards number 156 e russian
road
the principle of development is
considered acceptable as as is the
design impact on neighbour amenity
and highways matters the recommendation
is therefore to approve the application
subject to the conditions as detailed
thank you thank you very much there
being no speakers does anyone have any
questions for the officer i'm seeing
lots of shaking heads let's move to a
debate
uh would anyone like to say anything if
not i propose that we grant in line with
the officer recommendation
can i have a second
councillor dixon seconding it uh in that
case let's move to a vote before we do i
i want to apologize to olivia quinn for
uh the way i spoke to all of us really
then
um i recognize she is doing her job um i
wanted to move things on quickly so i
apologize for my bluntness
um let's move to the vote uh councillor
richards
four councillor fleming
muted yeah yeah reverse it
uh cancer flaring for councillor kendall
councillor kendall abstain
chancellor graham that's the crop for
councillor dixon council addiction for
cancer seraphin council interest in four
and councillor males council mills four
chair that's six four and one abstention
thank you very much olivia the committee
therefore resolves the grant application
twenty zero zero five nine seven
f u l in line with the recommendation
there being no further business i
declare the meeting closed at 901
thank you all
right council richard nice chair okay
guys so just bear with it close